anh alo alo chào các bạn
Nghe có vẻ rất ít như vừa rồi Kiểu có
ông đã hào hứng vào xem quan điểm bạn
gái thôi a
Galaxy không định chất ít như thế nhưng
mà chắc à đã từng có vài ông cũng
cô đã từng hỏi tôi về kiểu chị cái tán
gái cũng như là kiểu anh anh cứ đổ chị
Nga hải vân vân như thế nào anh chạy qua
bao nhiêu mối tình rồi còn Vân thì hôm
nay tôi đi
trả lời con điểm của tôi là cái việc này
Ê mày có
khi bật có 34 người xem à tôi định phát
video này Thứ nhất là tôi sợ cũng ăn bản
quyền đấy bởi vì trong video quá nha
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung là video là khá hay
từ 2016 đề Bây giờ nó là Vân 55 chứ Vậy
là 45 thôi ở vì mấy ngày này năm trước
mình xem mà
em ở đâu 5555 Sắp thành 6 năm thôi
khi video này thì các bạn xem xong người
mình mới nói con điểm của mình về cái
thằng đài sau bây giờ tập 12 phút 31
31 cộng thêm 12
43 rồi tất cả thoải mái từ 45 sẽ được 15
Xem do đó thì vào bài học và vừa nghỉ
ở ngoài ta mình sẽ con cái gì nhỉ
Ừ anh đúng rồi còn cái có cái nhóm này
các bạn cũng có thể vào xem này phải nhỏ
mà baby chứ
ăn kẹo mít restore camille theo là tội
không khuyến khích Mời ông vào kênh và
cãi nhau mới lắm với việc ngắm lấy tôi
thấy rất ra bình luận nó hơi bị à
có một chiều trời
Ừ nếu không biết là ngon mày không nhận
con yêu người khác tẩy chay nhiều đấy
nhằm đấy bị ăn phốt khá nhiều Maybe
you miss vip local News
ở đây nhó bị tẩy chay khá nhiều
ở ngã ba đường nhưng cũng rất là đông
đảo bài đăng Nói chung là tin tức thì nó
về cái đội tí nữa bạn có nhưng mà mình
đoạn gì được ra nó hơi bị một chiều quá
nó cả amin cũng ủng hộ cái một chiều ra
là kiểu Tôi thấy rất là nó không phải
môi trường thân thiện để mà mình giao
lưu ở trong này
không phải Giao lưu trao đổi trong này
vì nhóm mày kiểu Tôi thấy đăng hơi bị à
anh chị về các quyền kiểu nữ quyền ra
ngồi động vật quyền kiểu gì thế Nam
quyền trong nhóm này không tồn tại
xe tay ga Tôi khuyên mấy ông bảo chị nên
đọc tin tức
à Còn cái nhóm này baby you never want
to remove it are nhóm này thường này
đăng những cái về bộ phim cá hay trong
ngày có cái phim mà tôi
Chị thấy nó phim của Châu linh chi nhỉ
Ừ để chuyển một trong số ít các phim có
chữa bệnh gì mà Tôi thấy giữa hai ờ ờ
em hẹn chỉ đời tôi phim trôi Châu Tinh
Trì nào gần như ai cũng có cái hay của
nó có nhiều cái hay nhưng mà Thì tôi à
cái phim này tôi mới xem lại thì
nó càng nói rõ thêm về cái việc là
châu tinh cái hay của Châu Tinh Trì mọi
người sẽ bỏ đấy hả nhà nhưng mà nó khác
với cái hài hành động
hay hài nhảm thực sự hành động là của
Chắc cái tra nữa nó khác bởi vì rất hay
chan phim hài hành động Đấy ra nó nó
cũng là về để giải trí là nhiều hơn nó
không ý nghĩa nhân văn gì cả con cái
hàng ngàn này ha nhãn của Châu Tinh Trì
nó nó có ý nghĩa nhân văn Khánh hiểu từ
cái bộ phim này cũng là bộ phim
các bạn biết rồi Cái phim quốc sản 007
vậy nhỉ Quốc sản 007
ngủ ngon cô gái hay phim hài Mình thấy à
Cái ý nghĩa của bộ phim mà rất là sâu
sắc lắm kiểu nó đúng kiểu Rồng á
khi gặp nhau cuối tuần hôi trước đã cười
vỡ trước đấy Nó kiểu hài châm biếm
A và cái câu cuối của cây cúc cuối bài
là ngày tới thể hai tiếng cười có nhiều
loại tiếng cười sâu sắc chính là đỉnh
cao của nghệ thuật hài
A và cái này cũng chắc ở cũng sẽ là cái
câu mà có thể Tí giờ sẽ hỏi các bạn đó
là
các bạn thấy cười vì cái điều gì
anh Bởi vì
khi mà mình khi mình cười về một cái đâu
ạ
thì tại sao mẹ cười Cười nó các bạn vừa
nghĩ vấn đề đấy chị ạ
hai
cây viết Khi mà cười một cái gì đó đôi
khi ở thực ra là mình có thể tự nhìn
thấy bạn thân mình trong đấy và mình
kiểu Nếu sang trường hợp đấy mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ ra khó xử em ạ thì đấy Cái
kiểu cười để một kiểu cười là sự như ông
cười ra bị ngã cả nạ cười khác khi mà
làm gì đó ngu xuẩn ngại ông Nghĩa ở mình
sẽ không được làm như thế nó buồn cười
anh đấy đấy Kiểu cười theo kiểu hả hả
Cười vì một cái gì đó điên rồ
em
có kiểu cười khác là kiểu cười hồi trưa
giờ vẫn loại nhiều kiểu cười lắm ông
không biết mấy ông ở Thế trưa thôi còn
kiểu ờ ờ có kiểu cười đáng yêu cơ mà kêu
kêu gọi vừa rồi bảo kê cười điên tức làm
gì ạ Không hiểu thằng cái nghĩ gì mà làm
thế có kiểu cười đáng yêu tất cả chỉ là
khi máu thấy có gì ở rất là đáng yêu là
sự con chó mèo Đà Nẵng và em bé này đã
làm những cái gì ở bao nhiêu mình buồn
cười cái cái cửa cái cười đấy Nó kiểu
cười đáng yêu
Ừ nó đôi khi là tôi hồi trước rồi còn
kết hợp cả hai cái nữa vừa điên rồi đàn
nhị động đó
à à Ừ nhưng mà tiếp theo của những cái
kiểu cười nữa
cái hay của Châu Tinh Trì này khi mà ông
hiểu được cái thâm thúy của nó thì cười
hoặc là giống như Gala Cười ông Cười cái
cửa cười nói kiểu cười châm biếm à
À mà tôi thấy cái kiểu cười đánh lên
trọng nhất trong tất cả các kiểu cười so
với kiểu cười giải trí hài nhảm Thực sự
bây giờ anh à Bây giờ không phải mỗi
Việt Nam nhiều ông phê phán mà Việt Nam
bây giờ kiểu YouTube nhiều 2000 quá
nhưng thực ra bên ngoại có đầy mà nhớ
những cái 2000 là như thế
khi tôi thực sự rất khó cười
ạ Và nếu mà thực sự các bạn các bạn mặc
lỡ đã từng cười sở thích đang thích cái
đấy Tôi nghĩ là các bạn cũng có thể cần
nhắc lại của gì à
Ừ mình cũng nên có tiêu chuẩn riêng của
cười không phải các bạn đâu cười không ạ
có ai xem bóng đá Toyota Tôi không phải
con người xem bóng đá lắm Tôi không biết
từ kệ mấy ông chưa Thôi từ nhà tao từng
chơi bóng đá trong tương thích bóng đá
trong khi
kiểu
đầu tiên là hội bé của bé
Tôi là một thằng gạo đã Nhút Nhát thì
cho
áo kiểu màu sắc mà đúng không sau đó thì
đi
ạ sau đó đi mấy anh chọn trong hàng xóm
vì anh ấy rủ đi đá bóng thì ok cũng đi
đấy Sau đó thì mình anh ấy bắt nạt mình
cứ bán hàng ở mặt đấy cái rồi chuyển đến
sợ bóng tối không ghét bóng đá và vẫn cả
đã sau đó hộ về sau còn cứ đến mùa thi
cử thì y rằng cũng là mùa bóng nữa cậu
Nhà tôi ngày mặt phố
ở phố cổ hai mặt phố nghe cái to đúng
không
nhà trong ngõ thôi nhưng mà gần ngoài
đường sau đó thi
đua xe gào rú âm loạn hết cả lên
anh không không ngủ được đúng 1 thi nữa
ăn cay thì ra cậu Cái bóng đá
Ừ chứ thực ra là bạn bè mà rủ đi xem cái
gì đó kể cả bóng đá bước cái gì Mình
không thích nhưng mà vợ ở nhà phong trào
à cứ chọn con chào Đi kiểu có dịp để anh
em ngồi toàn đoàn tụ với nhau nói chuyện
với xem cái gì đó cùng nhau cũng được
ý nghĩa Tôi không thích bộ môn này lắm
nhưng mà tôi sẽ không hẳn ở ghét nó vẫn
thấy nó có nghĩa của nó để mọi người
đoàn tụ với nhau mà nó mạnh
nhưng mà những lúc đoàn tự đấy có nhận
tôi hơi khó xử khi mà người ta hỏi không
Đội bóng bạn thích rồi
hay là kiểu
nói chung là chị ạ tuyển thủ bạn thích
chịu
Anh biết mỗi vài cái tên nổi tiếng thôi
à
a spotify
chú ý mạnh là cái na
nghe spotify
Ừ cái này là
ứng dụng nghe nhạc mà cái ứng dụng này
mình thấy là để mà so sánh nó với những
cái ứng dụng nghe nhạc khác những như
mình từng dùng 13zing này YouTube music
nè
Nhạc Của Tui này
cho Oppo music kỹ thuật ra chưa Nhưng đã
loại trong bịch Ờ đấy
à à Đúng là phía trước có các trang chia
sẻ nhạc nữa thì cây spotify nó rất là ổn
ở địa là nó có nó bạn có ai ai này mà
nhận diện nhạc nó hơn cái thằng bờ
badinh ở đề xuất về thằng mp3zing ở đề
xuất để xuất đi xét lại mình cái bài
đang nổi còn hàng YouTube đề xuất thì
cũng à
nghe spotify bao nhiêu
a Sports Sports
Ừ ông kia nói
ở đây spotify con Ừ ông kia Cái xanh ra
rồi shop
ở Sapa pfizer free fire shopify cái khác
rồi
a
free fire là cái trang thương mại điện
tử khác tôi ở tưởng hỏi cái này
ở Hà Nội anh yêu đang nói giờ cái
spotify thì nó có cái ai nó đề xuất ổn
hơn hàng YouTube và như tốt vì tôi thấy
tôi phải mở ẩn nhanh lên thôi mình thấy
được những cái bài mới còn không có đề
xuất lại như cái bài cũ rất khó chịu
a
parasitic file đấy Được ca là tôi khuyên
mày ông qua để làm cũng được nó hình như
nội dung tiết p rồi Vậy cho nó không
dùng level đâu Nó dùng mà vương quốc của
nó riêng gì vậy không nhiều lắm
Ừ Ông kia bảo Xem giải trí nhưng không
chứ không xem những thứ vô nghĩa ở thôi
chưa hiểu câu hỏi không lắm đối với rồi
cái đối với tôi thì cái giải trí thì
cũng như tôi hôm trước tôi có cho mấy
người xem về mày kênh YouTube cho xem ấy
thì đời tôi những kênh giải trí rồi ta
cũng nên có chọn lọc một ý nghĩa có động
đám giấy chứ không hay đổ vô bổ hay vô
thưởng vô phạt cơ thế
I mean mean giống như kiểu tóc mi2k từ
ấy thì tôi có xem qua rồi bây giờ à xem
cái đấy được ra nó hài đấy và giống như
kiểu mấy ông nước rẽ Credit ủy ông lướt
cả ngày đêm cũng vừa hết với nó nó diễn
đàn với cậu đăng liên tục nóng lạnh cả
thế giới đang mà nhưng mà ở
Nói chung là cái việc đi sâu vào một cái
như thế quá ông bị hiểu
Ừ ông đúng kiểu không có thời gian làm
việc khác luôn Mày cứ mùi nước lớn ướt
cái dáng nhận thế này là kiểu ống hạn
chế mới đấy thôi mình Mình đã quen rất
nhiều bạn
cũng kiểu lướt lướt predator đấy cách
lưu dữ cũng cũng cải thiện tiếng Anh ấy
Tôi thấy công nhận là mấy ông mà nếu
thích một cái gì đó thôi mấy ông cậu
kiểu bị ám ảnh nó do mấy ông cũng thấy
dần nó quen nên thành ao học tiếng Anh
rất tốt nhưng mà nhược điểm thì như tôi
vừa nói nó là kiểu uống hết thời gian
làm những thứ khác rất hay đi thì lúc
ảnh ai mà
có kinh nghiệm practice hiệu quả
nhiệm cho thực hành thí nghiệm thực hành
thì
không các bạn chỉ cần nghĩ làm cái để
một cái đề bài nó do các bạn cứ làm
em
làm sau đó Tối như nó nghĩ kiểu nên tối
rồi thêm thì nên thêm tính năng gì thì
thì các bạn sẽ dần dần cải thiện được
trình độ thôi
sau khi mà khá Speed khá căng thẳng
không nghĩ ra được Nhốt ấy thì tốt nhất
các bạn Đừng có ngồi đấy nữa các bạn nên
phải làm việc khác các bạn nên các thư
giãn hồi trước là tôi gói cho thì cần
tôi khuyên về ông ngay ở Hà Nội Tôi từng
hay đi
gội đầu
anh không biết mày ông con trai như thế
không Tôi rất thích đi hội là tôi con
rùa anh Mạnh tôi đi gội đầu không Tôi vợ
anh ấy nghiện nhất là con trai mình gội
đầu không có xài còn mày Hà Nội người ta
sẽ dạy cho
đựng tôi con người thì ra không chịu
được cái đau nhưng mà người ta sẽ nói
cho làm cho đầu mình rất sạch
và thơm nữa vậy người ta dùng đủ loại
dầu tiếp theo là người ta sẽ xoa bóp cho
mình cậu ạ gọi là nếu rửa mặt nữa thì ra
là đông dù Cái Thảo đi nhưng Việt Thảo
Như bị lây cảm với mặt đi ra trạm mặt
ông cứ ngồi cười của buổi đấy thì à
khi
người ta sẽ nói cho mát xa mặt một cách
cứng đổi cho mình cái thư giãn Còn nếu
mà Mấy ông thực sự có thêm nhiều tiền
hơn đấy chỉ mấy ông có thể đi tẩm quất
chồng con lành mạnh như không phải tẩm
quất gì đó đâu và spa sản ạ Có spa nói
gọi không cần phải chơi mày các loại
speaker cửa là dưỡng da hay cái gì đó
Tiền đâu có thứ Nói chung là để đấy đầu
như bạn cái bảo để người massai để mình
thư giãn ấy hồi trước hồi mà đoán một
của tôi tôi ngồi cốt đồ ăn một kiểu bờ
thì tôi học buổi chiều buổi sáng tôi
được nghỉ nghe tôi toàn theo kiểu là
cốt đến 23 giờ đêm rồi tôi bắt đầu đi
ngủ thì ngồi đối diện nhà tôi là có quán
spa nó kiểu bia Khách quen và hàng xóm
đây Mày đang mở được cho mình vào lúc 2
giờ sáng ạ 2 giờ sáng người ta mở trong
mình vào và Hồi đấy tôi còn Mua con bồ
như chị có 1 từ
100.000 được một tiếng người ta massage
cho anh cái năm để nghe nhạc chuông
Dương do đó thì được cẩu được massage
Thái Dương Để mà giải tỏa cái đấy
anh sau cái đầu ăn một kiểu bình thường
Nhiều người sẽ thức khuya cảnh như thế
bộ bạn rồi mặt bao nhiêu mụn này xong
rồi cậu đến thâm nữa cứ sau một thì tôi
trông trắng trẻo hơn Hương ơi cho da dẻ
da mặt hồng hào theo cứ ngày nào được
spa rồi đấy Hồi đấy tôi cảm thấy sướng
với anh nữa kìa cứ ngồi cốt xong cấm học
qua được thư giãn Nghe nhạc tóc tách
Dương phải đúng tiền thì đưa mượn ở đây
tôi càng thấy yêu ấy yêu cái ngành nghề
này Vãi cả mình cứ làm được xong rồi
mình được rồi sạc cái hạn như thế Thế
lại thoải mái rồi à ờ ờ
anh alo
Ê con chó nó lại xổ con mèo rồi cứ đến
giờ giờ này thì rằng bọn nó lại nói
chuyện nhau cãi nhau Ok bây giờ hơi lan
man tí rồi Đúng con đúng với hai phút
tròn để mà chúng ta lại xem video mà hy
vọng là nếu như có đánh bản quyền với
nhá trong này có nhà Đấy
Tôi vừa tra cái video này trên YouTube
nó có đúng 1 cái mà thấy không có ghi
bàn khuyên gì cả nhưng hi vọng quay
video xem video này không bị sao nên
trong video đến cuối bài nó có nhà
Vì thế nên là hi vọng không bị ăn mòn
quen
khi
tôi nhận ra tôi yêu này ngay từ lúc đó
một tình yêu sếp này về từ cái nhìn đầu
tiên à
anh
[âm nhạc]
nói cho chính xác đó không phải là lần
đầu tiên tôi gặp nàng hai đứa vốn là bạn
cùng lớp hồi cấp 1 Nhưng ngày đó là cả
của tôi con gái mà quậy phá đanh đá hay
là con trai xưng là đại ca nữa chứ mà
vẫn thường trực nhất chính là tôi đã có
những lần tôi khóc sinh của vận chuyển
trường thì trốn nó không thành công thôi
thì bảo đi một thời gian rất lâu cũng
phải 10 năm rồi thì không thì nghề đó đã
trở thành thiên thần của lòng tôi à
ở lâu ngày không gặp đại ca đã không
chào nó còn chung vẫn nhìn à
múa là đúng không
ê ê
ở
đại đây
đã lớn rồi vẫn ngoan gì
em yên tâm tao không đánh mày nữa đâu
Vì sao giống gì có gì
anh
[âm nhạc]
vào số lần gặp lại đó tôi trở thành
khách hàng quen thuộc của quán trà sữa
nên là làm việc cũng là chỉ có thể hàng
ngày nhìn thấy này làm gì rất bận rộn và
hiếm khi có thời gian trò chuyện nhưng
mỗi khi tranh thủ được thì chúng tôi
thực sự rất vui Tình Yêu Sét Đánh của
tôi ngày càng thúc đẩy tôi phải tìm cách
nói ra à
ừ ừ
mở cửa thích cậu
Ừ thế
Ừ
thôi
không em không lên đâu
thời gian này mình
không muốn yêu đương gì hết
Thông cảm nha à
à
[Vỗ tay]
[âm nhạc]
Cậu Trang đó là bạn cùng lớp đại học của
nàng định gạt ta còn bị từ chối thì chắc
có lẽ tôi à
ừ ừ
Ừ ừ bạn bè Vậy cũng đủ vui rồi
Anh
[âm nhạc]
Hello
Sao mày hôm nay không đến
Dạo này tao bận xem nào sắp đến
Valentine
mày đi hẹn hò đúng không
làm gì có chuyện đấy
nói dối Nhìn cái mặt vuông có vẻ ta biết
phải làm sao
không
hẹn hò thì cũng đang theo đuổi hoặc là
thích một câu nào đấy đúng không
biết ngay mà
Ừ
vậy thôi
anh không chữa bệnh
Ừ
anh làm nha
Em
thấy chưa cái
lên đi
tao sẽ bắt này khi ra không sớm thì muộn
nhá á
Ý anh nói là lần đầu tiên tôi không nghe
lời hung thần Nếu làm như cách đây chục
năm thì còn lại đã này là dẫn dắt
những ngày sau đó là những nỗ lực và cố
gắng của làm chỉ khiến cho tôi hai và bí
mật để gọi có vũ lực có là mẹ cũng có và
tôi cũng hiện ra bí mật này chuyển cho
tôi trở nên dũng cảm hơn đang lý hơn chỉ
đứng trước mặt mà vẫn rất ngạc nhiên
nhân dân làng bắt đầu chuyển sang mềm
mỏng từ hối lộ chụp Đỗ tôi khi ra bí mật
đến cả Năn nỉ ỉ ôi chẳng ngờ xảy ra là
loại tò mò tọc mạch một triệu chứng của
bệnh gì
Ừ
thôi Vậy mày không khai đọc tha cho mày
đấy Tao bận
Ừ nhưng mà ít ta không kể cho ta biết cô
là ai thì cũng phải nói cho tao biết cô
là người thế nào chứ
Ừ thôi Mày đừng có tâm làm gì cả
à hay là
không phải là cô nàng nào hết mà là
anh chàng lấy đúng không
vào cùng
thì thôi vậy thì khai khai đó lâu đâu
đâu đâu rồi từ từ Tao nói tao nói ý
Ừ rồi kể đi
bộ
phim
Cô ấy là một cô gái xinh đẹp
[âm nhạc]
người thân thiện dễ gần
một người dịu dàng
đang mệt
và còn
kinh tế nhạy cảm à
[âm nhạc]
anh nói chung là vậy
Mày kiếm đâu Cô Nàng Hoàn Hảo thế chứ
Hay là tự tưởng tượng là đó
em không coi co thắt lại
vì vậy
tỏ tình trước
về chưa
Ừ tao sợ bị từ chối lắm
anh nói cả cũng không biết nói như thế
nào ạ
em
cứ nói nói
thật lòng mình
lời tỏ tình chân thật nhất bao giờ cũng
hoàn hảo nhất à
em đừng khinh rồi lại ca tao tao cũng
hiểu em rồi Chuyện tình cảm chứ
Ừ
thôi
tao đi làm việc em ạ
à Chị ơi
chị mua rồi chị ạ ạ
ở đây
ở cái nơi mà tôi nãy giờ nhắc đến là
à à
khi bị bé
chứ không phải không phải ạ
Ừ tao hả
Ý là tao hả
từ
thật thật
lợn là tao hả
Dạ có như tao chưa làm gì cả ta chơi gì
cả
[âm nhạc]
Hầu hết chúng ta đều chỉ có những mảnh
ký ức rất lời về những tháng năm học cấp
1 nhỏ quá mà điều mà tôi còn nhớ nhất
của những năm tháng đi học đầu đời là
cậu bạn mọt sách ngày quát Wow kính cận
dày chủ đầu và học và những rơi từ trên
cung trăng xuống chả hiểu ra hồi đó tôi
thấy rất ngứa mắt và thích bắt nạt cậu
ấy bạn cậu phải làm đệ tử lẽo đẽo đi
theo tôi và làm mọi thứ tôi yêu cầu
khi lớn lên và Gặp lại chồng cậu ấy vẫn
một sát vào nghề lắm nhưng chẳng hiểu
sao giờ tôi lại thấy có gì đó đáng yêu
và thật thu hút
có nhiều người bảo tôi sẽ rất đẹp đôi
với cậu bạn này nhưng tôi lại chẳng có
cảm giác gì trong khi đó ở thời gian ở
cạnh cậu ấy lại tràn ngập niềm vui và
tôi được là Chúng mình
liệu cậu ấy nghĩ gì về tôi Tôi muốn hỏi
những Vậy thì mất mặt lắm
chắc chắn tôi không phải là kiểu người
con gái mà cậu ấy thích
Ý tôi là một cô gái xinh đẹp
em
là người
từ thiện dễ gần
và một người dịu dàng
đang mến
A và còn
tinh tế nhạy cảm
một người tuyệt vời hoàn hảo nào đó khác
hẳn với tôi à
[âm nhạc]
Ý
là tao hả
thế nhưng hóa ra đó chính là cách cậu ở
Mỹ về tôi thật lợi là tao hả
[âm nhạc]
dọn Coi như tao chơi được gì cả tao chơi
cái gì cả à
Ôi trời ơi từ đây được tải thì làm sao
mà tao biết nó cả với ta
chú ý
khi
[âm nhạc]
chúng tôi đã bắt đầu hẹn hò như thế sẽ
chẳng bao giờ đạt được Nếu cả hai đứa cứ
giúp trẻ mà giữ kín tình cảm của mình
yêu thì cứ nói do thôi sét đánh rùa rụt
rè nhưng vẫn chưa kết thúc những ngày
dài đơn này và cảm giác đó thật tuyệt
vời
bên này không Chút yêu
nói dối ngày bình bia nồng nàn tha trao
nhau suy vướng Tiên ơi
Ừ thôi thôi các bạn mở kể nhạc về nghe
sau nhé Không ăn bật viên đấy Ok mấy hôm
đúc kết nối với cháu mẹ ôm 2 phút Hai
phút trả lời nó cũng đúc kết rồi đi 8
giờ rồi 8 giờ hạ 2 phút thôi chả được
ừ ừ
15 đốt Các điều gì sau video vừa rồi
ngoài việc Bạn ký sinh
Tình yêu là phải nói ok
những video không có nghĩa lắm
ở
nhà ông đúc kết được mỗi xảy ra thế thì
tán gái không tán gái được rồi chết
anh
nói ra sau này không hối hận không nói
ra sau này vẫn hối hận vì nói ra rồi
cùng chả được cái gì cả
các bạn tuy khá ngon
Ừ vậy thế giờ rồi gì mà Xinh mà có phải
để chén đâu
Tình
yêu là ngồi ăn cơm chó của người khác
khắp tôi thì tôi không biết mấy ông thế
nào nhưng tôi từng rất thích nhìn cái
cặp đôi khác yêu nhau bởi vì là cái cả
khi tôi độc thân nhé Buổi tối có nhìn họ
thấy à Tình yêu nó vẫn còn tồn tại tôi
vẫn tin tưởng vào tình yêu được nếu bây
giờ sự chẳng còn ai yêu nhau ông Lê News
ông Toàn lọc mình cái bài về về thất
tình chia tay rồi đồ bỏ thì ông sẽ mất
hết niềm tin vào tình yêu
tán gái là phải trên thành cũng quá sai
và đương nhiên thì tôi không nói ông bị
tư tưởng passport hay làm gì cả đang nói
là đúc kết từ cái video rồi không phải
như thế
à à
Ừ ok nửa gần Rau hẹ mày nó cũng đúng một
phần cũng đúng một phần thôi Bây giờ tôi
OK nhá Đây con điểm của tôi tán gái mà
gần ngờ gần như là tôi đã anh tôi khẳng
định là tôi thành công lý phải 90 phần
trăm Và tôi đúc kết được nó như thế này
ờ ờ đừng bao giờ chào con gái biết được
để bạn mấy bạn nữ xác nhận được cơm đấy
bạn nữ không biết điều này đâu con gái
được có một cái tư tưởng tôi thấy nó bị
như nào nhỉ con trai được ra thích chinh
phục con gái ở cá thích đố kỵ lẫn nhau
đôi khi ở thích một cái Sợ vợ cũng chinh
phục nhưng mà kiểu đó
à Cậu nó mà vẫn dùng từ như thế nào nhỉ
sở hữu ở tủ lạnh sở hữu Mình thích cái
thứ mà người ta muốn có đôi khi em không
cần có nhưng mà nhiều người muốn thành
là mình tự nhiên mình thích nó chả thế
không nói con trai đôi khi và đứa con
trai lắm thế thôi Nếu nó là con gái
thường ai gọi tính đố kỵ của như thế hơn
em này cái thứ nhất thứ hai đó là ờ
Anh ở khi mà vì cái tình đấy thế này khi
mà đứa con gái mà biết được là ông những
thích nó kể cả rồi nó có thích không Đôi
khi đôi khi nhé Nó sẽ tự nhiên hết thích
ông rồi và nó sẽ không không đồng ý cho
sự như thế
Ừ tôi đã từng đúng kiểu như thế luôn ý
đó bạn kia là con thích mình khi biết
được Mình thích họ khi người ấy từ cháu
luôn về chưa ạ
Ừ cái cái video vừa rồi nó cũng mà như
thế đi ra vừa rồi chẳng qua là à
Ừ nếu mở file đúng không đúng khi mà đứa
này không biết được thằng con trai thích
mình cái nha đứa ăn gà Nó rất là thoải
mái tự nhiên với thằng nhái kia nó không
nó không tạo ra cái bức tường rào cản để
mà thằng kia nó làm đứa con gái nè mùi
lòng mất rồi và đứa con gà nó chủ động
trước con gái rủ động chưa vừa rồi không
thấy con gái phải rửa rộng trước thì ông
mới dễ Hán mời ông mà dễ chinh phục được
bạn đấy thứ nhất là ông vẫn phải không
phải ông lên fanzone mà ông vẫn vẫn phải
có một cái gì đó để mà
để mà cọ khiến cho người ta có tình cảm
với mình nhưng mà không không nên cậu
giống như cụ câu cá Đừng để nó gì hết
mồi lúc mà ông giật lên Ông chẳng có
được cái gì đâu thế làm chưa đừng để con
gái rồi thây ông quá đến nỗi là cậu nó
còn chẳng muốn yêu đã nó muốn chị chỉ
làm bạn thôi được rồi đấy Ừ ông đừng có
thân quá rồi mới bắt đầu như thế mà
không phải
Anh ở ông ông phải cậu gần như là cũng
tạo khoảng cách vẽ tương đối để mà đứa
con cái cảm giác muốn muốn ông chỉ của
riêng nó không chỉ ở mức bạn bè nữa
Ừ nhưng mà Cái quan trọng là à
Anh hello ông phải có cái gì nó muốn
Chinh Phục Ông nào không ạ Đấy Và đừng
bao giờ xong nó biết được ông Thịnh nói
trước luôn luôn là thế nhờ cầu Xương Sơn
tụi nó sẽ không mở được cho con gái biết
nó thích bởi vì không thì đường dài sẽ
luôn Tạm giàu cái họ tạo ra cạn với ông
và ông sẽ không có cơ hội để mà phát
triển tình cảm được đâu
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi hôm nay chắc là nhiều người
mất tích gì đó tôi thấy có hẳn trực tiếp
như thế mà cứ cùng hơi thì
ít à
ở đó là nhiều người không biết bạn gái
chẳng hạn thế một nửa số người xem của
tôi là nữ nào ạ
anh nhờ bạn nữ nào vào xác nhận cái tôi
vừa nói Tôi tin là cái đấy nó một phần
đúng các bạn thử nghĩ em nữa
nó thôi Bây giờ trả trả trả lời
Ê mày có hỏi đã nha và bài học nhé
Em thấy thế nào khi một bạn nữ dùng cái
gọi sắc đẹp để của mình để làm mọi thứ
thay vì trau dồi tri thức họ cho đời sắc
đẹp và họ thấy thế là đúng là có quyền ạ
ạ Cái cái quan điểm này thức khá hay
từng khá nhiều người nghĩ rồi đấy tội
Tôi nghĩ rồi đấy đó kèo à
anh nói nhà nghỉ thật ra thì cái đấy
người ta bị bết biến kiến lợi thế của
mình thành thật biết phát triển các lợi
thế của mình thôi nhưng mà tôi không ngủ
tôi không hẳn ủng hộ cái đấy Họ là chính
họ mà nó không ạ
Ừ nhưng mà nếu mà họ mà biết kiểu thêm
được nữa gọi gọi như nào nhỉ
em đem vô dơ có cái câu đó là ở
là con gái mà biết được họ
Tra cứu điểm của họ là gì thì đấy đấy
tôi nhớ để Thôi trả lại cái Bố giờ của
tôi đã PowerPoint I
à à
Ai
bảo ai của tôi
à À cái này không liên kết với cái tài
khoản của tôi rồi
Ừ nếu không nên cái gọi
Em chúc bác Ôi tôi hồi trước ở có cái
câu hay về con gái mà biết được lợi thế
của họ đúng là một thế lực luôn đấy như
thế
đã
từng chạy theo Mối tình ca có thì tôi
tôi từng chạy theo mối tình nữa cái bạn
mà tôi cay đắng nhất đi Tôi bảo với mấy
ông về tôi cay tôi tôi tán lại bạn thích
đại tôi rồi cùng đi Cuối cùng thì do là
ngay từ lúc đầu tao tỏ tình rồi sau đó
về về sau thì bạn ấy cũng có thích nhưng
mà bạn ấy
đấy đấy chính là cái kính nghiệm xương
máu tôi nói đó là đừng để cho đứa bạn
phải biết được trước hay là kiểu cho tôi
Họ có thích họ vẫn cầu họ kiểu dãn cái
bảo thủy họ sẽ cố cố không tin vào cái
tình cảm của mình anh khẳng định hộ còn
thích nhé vì họ họ mà không thích kỳ họ
rõ ràng là từ chối xong rồi Thôi ông
chuyện này nào đi chơi cùng mình được đi
chơi hẹn hò cùng một mình
đấy không phải một sự bạn tốt ở đây rồi
các bạn tình ngày âm rồi à Người ta theo
đuổi mình mình chạy
Ẩm Thực ra là cũng có vài bạn đã từng
thưởng thích tôi và tôi thực ra đây có
có trường hợp từ chối có tường hợp và
kiểu thực ra chưa quen họ chưa biết họ
thì chả nghĩa là mình cứ thử hẹn hò sẽ
nào đi cho một vài buổi không ổn thì
thực ra bạn ấy cũng thấy không ổn thì
thôi ông ạ
Ừ thôi thì con điểm nó về tình cảm thì
vợ về tuổi trẻ của tôi con đỉa mà giờ
thoải mái mình không làm gì đón nhận về
sau được nên là hẹn hò Thực ra sáng là
nhiều Tôi không phải do tôi không phiên
mấy ông nên làm thế vì gì ạ
anh đấy đấy có nhược điểm của tôi đó làm
chị Tôi hẹn hò quá nhiều Thành ra hả cậu
nó có sự so sánh mấy ông hiểu không Ông
hẹn hỏi ý chị ông không được sao sàng
đâu ông hẹn hỏi nhiều nặng có sự so sánh
trong đầu cũng có kiểu người này người
kia người này tốt điểm này người kia tốt
hơn kia ông đó Xong rồi ông
anh cũng bị nạn nhiều mà tốn kém nữa hẹn
hò nhiều tốn kém vãi khám quan điểm là
thằng con trai thằng đa năng
Em đang làm bạn thì đừng nói lời yêu ấy
Thế thì ông không xem teamview review nó
nữa không có tình bạn khác giới thực ra
đối với tôi thường ra cái quan điểm tình
bạn khác giới thở ra nó có nhưng mà nó
phải nằm trong mấy cái trường hợp sau
trường hợp 1 là
hai người đều có người yêu hả rất yêu
người đấy rồi chẳng gặp hai đó là đứa
gái nó bị điên phải dùng từ bị điên ấm
thìa điên Nói chưa từng thử tán một đứa
hiểu Điên vãi chưởng đấy và không thể
đoán được bởi vì nó buồn à Vợ Cuồng thần
tượng nó bến hàm cơ được Thế nó có gọi
thần tượng ở chồng lúc nào chị đang thì
yêu mỗi châm thôi không phải đạt được
trường hợp 3 thì khi hai người kiểu dạng
bà à
ở chỗ hai người có hả Đúng rồi cho ba
đứa con gái rất xấu thì được ăn cái rất
xấu nó khó hơn đứa con trai rất xấu con
gái thì không yêu vào mắt bằng con trai
nên thành ra là con gái vẫn chấp nhận
được con trai xấu của con trai đôi khi
kiểu nó hơi bị nhạy cảm thấy cái việc
đấy
cho nên là có thể nó sẽ là bạn tốt thật
thôi Anh nói mấy cái đôi khi nó rất tế
nhị có nhiều bạn ở đây sẽ thấy nhẹ cả
tôi khẳng định luôn nhưng mà đợi đấy đấy
một vài cái A
Ừ nếu ghét đang làm cái gì nữa
á hậu tôi xem tivi của xem hội để xem
một vài cái hồ sơ không xem thằng Dương
đâu ạ
à Nó thích con trai nhưng mà nó Nó kiểu
bị điên quái thành là khó tán không tán
được rồi không tán được
trong đâu Nó chỉ có mỗi anh đấy người ta
như thế nào được
ở nhà bé ông có điểm như thế nhưng mà
cái những cái trường hợp Tôi vừa kệ nó
trường hợp để mà hai đứa không hề có
tình cảm với nhau còn giống như nhiều
đứa nhà ấy bảo là
em chỉ coi anh đấy là bạn thôi mà Thì
đưa là
cho
tôi đã từng nói câu đấy hướng yêu cũ rồi
ăn gì à cái thằng kia nó còn thẳng con
tỏ tình hỏng với cái người yêu của tôi
sẽ rồi rõ ràng à Thằng đấy nó học cùng
lớp tôi cơ nghe vậy thằng ấy học cùng
lớp tôi sao thấy tỏ tình của video của
tôi rồi biết thôi tự nhiên Bọn tôi yêu
nhau rồi không ạ Đấy xong rồi mẹ con kia
vẫn
bạn kia nhỉ Bạn kia vẫn nhắn tin nói
chuyện Thằng này như bạn thân vậy rồi
Bạn em chỉ coi thằng đấy là bạn thôi mà
Thì thực ra đối con gái thì thấy bạn
khác giới nhưng mà để mà rạch ròi ra cái
từ bạn khác dưới đây Nó là phải là không
phát triển tình cảm từ cả hai phía còn
một phía thì vẫn không được tính là bạn
khác giới
à Xong rồi Thậm chí là bà Ok em con đấy
là bạn nhưng mà không có em ở bạn đấy
thôi bạn không nó vẫn còn em và bạn mà
Nếu thế thì bây giờ em thử nhắn tin cho
nó bảo là tao chia tay thằng Long rồi mà
chúng ta yêu nhau được không Xem nó có
nói câu là
thôi chúng mình chỉ nên làm bạn thôi
không trả lời nói câu đấy rồi đúng không
ạ
Không không đối với bạn ăn cái thực sự
rất thích của bạn tha rồi và đúng là bạn
ấy có thể không phát triển tình cảm thật
bạn lấy chung thủy thật nhưng mà thằng
con trai kia nó không có tư không có tư
tưởng đấy không có tư tưởng chống phá
mối quan hệ của mình nên thành ra nó vẫn
là sai
Ừ cái tươi tình bạn phá rồi đổi tôi là
phải tình bạn thân tiết à thần Khuyết
thần Khiết hoàn toàn trong xã hoàn toàn
từ cả hai phía chứ không phải từ một
phía từ một phía như thế thì đấy là ông
coi nó là bạn còn nó không coi không ạ
Ừ Vậy thế nên là vừa rồi với bà đã có ba
cái trường hợp ngoại lệ có thể xảy ra để
mà chắc chắn ạ Không có tình cảm thì cả
hai phía ý
ai cần túi đó ngoài kia dễ
ạ Bây giờ có rất nhiều bạn gái giờ đang
có bạn khác giới thật nhưng bây giờ bạn
thử nhắn tin mấy cái thằng đấy rồi bảo
mình yêu nhau đi xem có bao nhiêu thằng
nó nhắn lại ở đó kiểu
thôi chúng mình chỉ là bạn thôi không
không A Gọi ít lắm ạ
Ừ
thế thế này là mấy ông
anh không thể khẳng định rồi đấy được
à à
a tiếp theo tôi hơi lan man tâm sự quá
về xin phép trả lời đúng ngoại ý
à à Dùng i5 trong máy của em
Ừ mình cũng muốn có bạn thân phát rồi á
Nếu thế thì ấy là tôi bảo rồi vừa rồi
trong ba được một là hai đứa có đều có
người yêu rồi và đều đi rất yêu người
kia thì gặp 2 đó là đường này nó bị điên
vãi trưởng thứ ba là đứa con gái xấu đứa
con trai xấu đứa nói muốn người yêu nhé
và trường hợp 4 thì có bốn giờ ra là cả
hai cùng có
hai kỳ quan điểm góc nhìn khác về dưới
tính theo kéo có đứa nó bị vô tính ở ạ
Thức ạ Tôi làm chỉ ra vô tình lúc nghỉ
nhớ vô tình hay gọi gì nhưng mà nó không
hề có cảm xúc gì với hai giờ chúng con
đấy hoặc là lắm chuyện nó có nó cảm xúc
với giới tính khác thế ạ câu thơ câu thơ
tập trung tập trung lại bạn kêu vào học
rồi Thôi cũng nên hoa thôi rồi rahman
quá Tôi sẽ thôi sẽ có khi nào sẽ
gọi trao đổi các bạn thì mình cái đấy
sau à
Ở đây có bạn hôm trước bảo là dùng cái
i5 ở trong máy queo thật sự có nhiều bạn
không biết là cái này để tôi chia sẻ với
ông rồi Cái này nó một cái rất là hay vợ
trong máy cao hôi mà tôi về với công ty
này tôi mới biết cái đấy cũng là một cái
giờ khi mà công ty áp dụng ngày nay toàn
thành ra nó bị Hơi sai Để tôi giải thích
cho bé ông Tại sao nó sai đây nhá cái
năm đấy nó là gì bố
mẹ tôi mở cái này đến cho mấy ông ạ
[âm nhạc]
em không có hô không phải mèo tôi phải
chạy ra xem có ai không
ở nhà tôi ở trong ngõ cho thuê nhà trong
ngõ mình ra kiểu hàng xóm đi qua khi con
này cũng sủa Nếu mà hàng xóm đứng ở
trước cửa trường cửa ngõ của người ta
chỉ dừng xe đỗ trước cửa ngõ tự nhiên có
lẫn chút à
khi xảy ra cậu này hơi nhạy cảm quá
ờ
ờ Ok thì bây giờ quay lại này
giờ sự mình có khách hàng có khách hàng
đó ngoạn Các bạn nhớ thế giới tính không
ạ bây giờ Hồi trước mình cho quy ước
không là không là giới tính là nữ chẳng
hạn một lần Lan ở ạ nhưng mà đôi khi là
các bạn muốn à truyền vào để mẹ hiển thị
ra cụ thể thay vì hiển thị mỗi số như
thế nhìn thị nam và nữ nhưng mà chỉ yêu
cầu là được Chỉ được phép triển nam với
nữ là chẳng hạn
Ừ thì bây ở như thế nào thì nó sẽ có
khái niệm y55 ở các bạn thể chuyển chuỗi
và ra chỉ được phép nằm trong những cái
chỗ ấy thôi à Sợ mình có trên đồ với ông
dùng từ trên đồng á méo đường thư dùng
thử sách nhá sách ra vẫn đúng rồi nhưng
mà không không nên dùng đấy thì cái Nam
này Đấy sau đó thì mới ông truyền dữ
liệu trong này thì ra tôi chưa thử vụ
nằm nhập bằng cái này đó là lưu mà để
thử nhé
mail này
vì vậy female này
chỗ mà không phải để uống rượu nhai đó
sau đó mình thì được
để lưu lại
từ lúc đầu đứng yên mới thêm vào thì cái
này nó đang bị chấm nó bị rỗng
à mà không là nó ký ức luôn Các bạn thấy
nó không được phép dẫn luôn mà chuyện
Male female nha alo được cái giống mà
tôi nhớ được phép giống như là nó chỉ
một trong ba ạ 132 thôi nó không được
phép nhập và 01 thì cả và đưa nó sẽ lưu
lại như này luôn thì cái năm này có lợi
ở điểm như tôi vừa nói đó là không được
nó là hộ cho mình vụ virus rồi đúng
không ạ nghĩa là nó không được nằm ngoài
phạm vi là nhập giới tính khác ở trong
này không ạ những và nó hiển thị ra được
lương kết quả và cái việc nó lưu lại nó
cũng sẽ nhẹ tương đương một việc là các
bạn lưu lại dạng in hoa khác nhẹ cho dù
các bạn đang lưu lại dạng chữ nhưng mà
Bởi vì a giới hạn chữ cái này ít cả Nga
nó lưu lại vẫn nhẹ trong bộ Tìm kiếm của
nó cho thấy tôi trao Google tốc độ hình
như tìm kiếm nó không đến nỗi nóng Tăng
lương soi tìm kiếm về với dạng y như vậy
à Nhưng cái này có bị nhược điểm một cái
có một cái rất lớn mà công ty bị dính đó
chính là
cái này thì ra nó lại nhược điểm liên
quan đến máy quý vào chữ loại lớn của
liên quan đến cái kiểu giới thiệu này
liên quan thì mai hết keo tại sao tôi ở
dùng thử máy queo không phải dùng
esquare Bởi vì các bạn ạ Mình tôi đã dậy
mấy ông về ép của server đúng ạ và máy
QR là cái mình đang học và được tất cả
cái này đều đang dùng AE chung đúng là
cái nền cái này cơ bản này sau đó thì nó
phát triển anh hai cái này không ạ Và
cái mà bên khác giờ sửa bên stress
bên một người ta gọi thằng abstract để
cậu thế Thi thì nó sẽ khác nhau ở điểm
gì mà thằng mai que O nó bị chết kể quay
Nami năm này các bạn thấy vừa rồi tôi
cho xem lại Cấu Trúc Các bạn xem nhé
cơ cấu trúc của cái này đi năm thành
dạng được là chỉ được truyền hai hai cái
trong này đúng không ạ Giá từ Giả sử Bây
giờ tôi muốn truyền thêm một giới tính
nữa đi đồ ngoại giới tính thêm nữa là
cái wifi hay tính kiểu
gai gì em ạ Các bạn biết dai không ra
đây là thứ ca nhiều không Thực ra con bị
nhờ một khái niệm gai tưởng ám chỉ ở con
trai giới tính
kiểu đồng tính nóng như gai được Từ đồng
tính chung của cả nam và nữ nhé đấy mới
biết đến khái niệm mới không đấy thì khi
và giả sử tôi thêm một cái gì tình này
nữa chẳng hạn để ra anh nha không ạ thì
mấy ông khi tôi nhận xét thì mày không
xem được câu chuyện nhé
em lại có suy vật nó sẽ như thế này
các
câu truy vấn ở đây nó sẽ enter Thay bồ
nó giúp ở trên đúng rồi nó có dùng người
trên đó đổi cột này thành cột như thế
này trông thấy
ý anh bảo em thóc em chửi nó làm gì em
thấy nó bình thường món chị đã già ạ Gọi
đến bảng này thôi cập nhật cột này thành
cột như thế này đúng ạ Không cái này thì
ra là không Nó rất sai khi mà không Để ý
kỹ cái này xong rồi cái câu lệnh Hôm
trước có bạn nói mình mình mới đi kỹ về
có lệnh và mình mới nhớ lại phải cái vụ
này mình chia sẻ lại các bạn
ở đây đây một ví dụ nhé đây ví dụ về để
đổi lại khái ví dụ này nó sẽ là gì Tôi
tóm lại trong mấy ông nhá hoan ta thấy
bồ thấy bồn em ở đây này có lum nêm này
không ạ hạn chỉ có thể Cái này vừa rồi
có thể đổi được tên cổ đi nhá nó có luôn
nên mới ạ ngu ngu đi
ở
Sao Đỏ thì triệu dữ liệu mới
Ừ đúng rồi lét làm thị nữ Nhưng mà gai
làm chị Chung được cả nam và nữ có
chứa người ta dùng ngay cho con trai
nhiều hơn này nhiều không biết
đây là đã thay này
có
ai gọi chấm chấm làm sao đúng không ạ
Bây giờ tôi cho mình không xem kể enter
which đ
đi tìm mấy ông sẽ thấy là câu lệnh của
nó khác nhau như thế nào
cho
iPad app J5 bên đấy ạ
thì nó sẽ như này thôi
có thêm 1,5 10 nhá thì nó sẽ là như thế
này ừ ừ
Ừ nếu thấy khác
Ừ cái này nhá Khi mà ông thêm một cái J5
ở bên mái queo về mày khuya rồi
nó sẽ sửa lại cả cái cột đấy nó sẽ sửa
lại cả cột Đấy tức là nó xóa cột này đi
copy dữ liệu cụt đấy Sang dữ liệu cột
mới
chỉ để thay đổi thêm một cái giá trị của
Ý năm con thằn stress thì nó sẽ làm cơ
chế là nó chẳng liên quan gì đến cái cột
cả nó sẽ kiểu cách cài i5 nó giống như
là một cái hàng số một con phần nó sẽ nó
sẽ cập nhật ở một cái chỗ khác nó thay
đổi giá trị của cây năm nhưng mà ở một
chỗ khác còn những cái cột mà dùng cái
năm đấy cột đấy không bị ảnh hưởng gì cả
Hình như tôi vừa nói ở đây máy theo
tướng nhấn mạnh này nhá đó là nó sẽ xóa
cột cũ và copy dữ liệu cột cũ sang cột
mới
a cho dù kể cả chị thay đổi mỗi kiểu đã
thay thận chứa hồi trước à
bên bên công ty Để tôi nó còn chỉ thay
đổi mỗi kiểu mấy ông nhớ về vụ sữa Trinh
ở đây ba chả đây tôi để 50 ở ngoại ô về
sau tôi tăng nó lên thành 200 à vì 50k
ngắn quá sau đó tôi chết tao bây phải
mất hai tiếng đồng hồ ngồi sửa nó bởi vì
À đấy Cái cái việc mà chỉ còn thay đổi
mỗi kiểu giới hạn nó cũng là được đội
đối với bên máy kia nhé cũng là việc xóa
cột cũ đi để copy dữ liệu cột cũ sang
cục mới thành ra là vui cái bảng ở công
ty tôi đang là
24 triệu bản ghi nó sẽ copy 24 triệu từ
cột cũ sang cuộn mới khi mà các bạn chạy
có gạch update mà ăn tết 24 triệu truy
vấn cùng một lúc đấy thì chết Chết luôn
đã trả lời
A và mình đã nói rồi mai Phèo mà không
phù hợp khi được lưu lại nhiều như thế
nhưng vừa về công ty mình đang dùng cái
đấy nên là mình à
vì mình không thể không thể chuyển được
nhưng mà cái việc là dùng vậy năm khi mà
cho cái bạn dữ liệu đầu như thế và khi
mà các bạn thêm một cái kiểu dữ liệu mới
cho cái năm đấy thì các bạn sẽ đồng
nghĩa việc là các bạn bị
chết như tôi vừa nói lời giải quyết cách
giải quyết ở đây Thực ra các bạn để ý
vừa rồi Tôi có tra các bạn xem này enter
time
ý nghĩa đổi Thiện dữ liệu cho một cột
của madewell ở trong bảng dữ liệu rất
lớn thì sẽ nên làm như thế nào nó sẽ có
nó sẽ thường có cái cách chơi nó hơi bị
củ chuối một tí đó là thường là các bạn
sẽ
tạo một cột mới
cách tạo lại cột mới
ạ sau đó đi đổi tên cột cũ thành một cột
obshi Z sợ gì đó
ạ sau đó thì các bạn sẽ chạy câu lệnh
update cũng đã update nhưng mà ăn tết nó
vẫn nhẹ hơn so với ăn tơ còn này bộ về
enter lại Đồng thời các bạn sẽ update
tầm ví dụ Trăm nghìn mà ghi 212 thường ạ
100 Khoảng 500.000 1GB cùng một lúc thôi
chứ để nhắc đến một phát 24 triệu bản
ghi cùng lúc
Ừ để mà
update lần lượt từ cột cũ sang quận mới
khi update xong hết thì rốt cột cũ đi
đấy mà chơi củ chuối như thế chứ Tránh
việc là các bạn sẽ ăn tôm như thế này
sửa một cột ở trong bảng 24 triệu Bạn đi
ở trong mai que em hôm đấy là hai tiếng
rồi còn ít đấy hai tiếng hay thì anh đấy
là hai tiếng Việt là đầu tiên chắc em
chết arabe rồi nên là tôi phải xóa câu
cầu ấy đi và phải nói chung nó copy như
tôi đúng cách câu vừa nói nghĩa là tạo
ra cục mới cho copy cột cũ sang cột mới
nên thành là mất 2 tiếng để ông ạ Chứ
không
Ừ chứ không có chuyện là kiểu các bạn
chạy được câu này trong sửa kiểu dữ liệu
ở trong ở trong bảng 24 triệu bảng ghi
em ạ Thế nên là tôi có nói mấy ông đó là
gì không được tự ý sửa datapes đấy bài
học xương máu rồi ạ
Đúng rồi Trăng ra thôi phải trong đó ra
thôi thậm chí nếu mặt nặng quá thì mày
chơi kiểu tạo ra Hàn mặc bảnh bạn kiểu
bạn một mạng hay gì đó không phải tạm
ngưng sót trước vào bảng 2 tiền mình Cập
nhật lại bạn một gì gì đó Cái đấy cách
đấy Cái giải quyết cũng là một cách tạm
thôi gì đó còn hơn kia gà update 1 phát
nhầm đấy Bạn ghi không có một database
rồi nó bởi vì nó chạy cái đấy nó treo
luôn làm chết tất cả những cái câu
chuyện cần khác mà đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ ok
trả lời câu lại khá dài tiếp theo về vụ
Con thích
a
complete ở code ga có tôi tôi chia sẻ
mấy ông dùng ghế rồi nhưng mà Chắc mấy
ông cũng mời như tôi thành ra là mày ông
cũng bị con scored thậm chị hôm trước
của các bạn phàn nàn bạn kia con fix
code về chính bạn đấy Tôi không hiểu mẹ
nếu con thích cốt chính bản thân mình
kiểu gì nhưng nhớ lại cái nó là ờ ờ
ở tại Khánh con Nick nó là gì Nói chuyện
xung đột cốt nghĩa là hắn chỉ là cốt của
ông so với cốt mà mới đẩy lên mới để lên
ở cốt của âm đẩy lên sau Cốt đã đẩy lên
trước đấy nó bị nó bị vấn đề vào cùng 1
dòng cùng một dòng mà cùng bị cũng bị
vấn đề đấy Nên là thằng ít nó không biết
lấy cốt dòng nào đông ạ thì cách để
tránh được ngoài là các bạn luôn phải
kéo Cốt về chứ không giỡn nói các bạn
phải kéo cốt từ trên Master về nhánh
gồng mình trước đã trước khi mà đẩy cốt
mới lên đấy ví dụ là sử đây các bạn sẽ
thưởng này khéo phải sang bên Master này
ở như này ăn full đã kéo hết Cốt về sôi
các bạn sẽ sang lại nhà ngay nhánh của
chính các bạn cho các bạn sẽ ấn a update
for Master này được cập nhật cốc mới đấy
Sau đó thì các bạn mới làm gì tiếp thì
làm các bạn phải làm thế trước khi đẩy
bất kì cốt nào lên để tránh xung đột
Complex rồi chị ạ
anh nghe cách giảm thiểu nhất thôi không
biết cái nào tối ưu hơn rồi tối Tất cả
cũng mới dùng tôi cũng mới dùng ít thôi
song ca
em mặc dù đam mê Nhưng mà cũng có thời
gian chán và khó Cái thứ thứ Làm sao để
vượt qua giống như vừa nãy tôi còn nói
với ông kia Cậu ngồi nghĩ mãi không ra
được cách giải quyết vấn đề đúng không ạ
Chị chỉ đơn giản là ông đừng có nguồn
nghĩ nữa
ô nhiễm sao ý ông được ông kiểu dạng
ngồi nghĩ nhiều nó sẽ ra vấn đề mà khóc
cái này gần giống như là cái thứ ra tôi
nhiều lúc tôi nghĩ là về cái thời gian
thi thử là nhiều quá nó hơi bị sai đã
từng là tôi đã tôi mình buồn cười về cái
việc là có một ông ở trong phòng thi của
tôi thức ăn mấy ông liền trong vòng thi
rồi ơi xin thêm thời gian để làm bài Cứ
khẳng định luôn mua khi mà không nghĩ ra
được Muốn vấn đề trừ khi mà bài nó có
dài ra sự môn toán Ok Nhưng mấy ông biết
ông ấy xin thời gian cho môn gì không ạ
muốn anh ạ mất f*** muốn anh và đặc biệt
đấy còn trách nhiệm chứ không phải viết
bài gì cơ quan trắc nghiệm Em muốn anh
làm một trong những môn học thuộc hạ
Ừ ông ông mà biết được đáp án ông khoang
rất nhanh còn mua khi ông không biết
được các bạn ấy thì ông ngồi bao nhiêu
lâu nữa thì ở không không bật ra được
cái gì đâu Cái này nó là như thế nó kiểu
dạng hả ông nghĩ là được cách giải quyết
thì nó rất là nhanh còn mùa khi nó không
nghĩ ra được ông ngồi mãi đôi khi nó vẫn
khác Và thậm chí nó còn ra sai nên thành
ra là không ông ông không nên kiểu cố cố
làm gì cả
chị đã tôi ở từng phải rất nhiều âm cối
tại 34 tiếng không chả làm được cái gì
Đúng rồi ông ở bị bề giác gì đó cái ngày
này có lợi thế như thế vào ngành này đưa
còn đang làm quốc phòng hôn đúng không
làm ở nhà thì ông càng được làm cho đấy
đó làm thấy bỏ bất cứ lúc nào được
à à
Ừ ông thể bỏ Sau đó thì ông ạ Ông kiểu
nút xác lúc khá ông ngồi làm tiếp được
coi Trách không được ông ngồi mãi ở đấy
không giải quyết vấn đề gì nữa Nó có
khiển sinh thêm vấn đề ngày ngày của
mình không phải nhàng mà bảo cần kinh
chi là đủ càng ngày này mình cần nào
cũng không cần ở thông minh mà mình cần
phải làm việc có hoa
Ừ thế này nhiều ông sẽ thấy da tôi ngồi
chơi có ngày tôi chỉ ngồi chơi thôi vì
tôi cảm thấy hôm ấy tôi không thể nghĩ
là cái gì cả đúng người nghĩ gì chỉ thêm
bất rồi nên hôm vậy thôi Ngồi chơi cũng
chẳng ai trách rồi tôi vụ đấy ạ
em có người hôm trước hỏi tôi thật ngu
thầy để làm gì ạ
với xin trả lời ở đây là À thì ra là các
bạn mà tìm được một người mà để mình
chưa chạy được đấy với tô con điểm đấy
thì nó sẽ khá là hay cũng sẽ ở vui hiểu
sẽ mình cảm thêm động lực để làm cái gì
đó
cho nên là mấy ông cũng nên kiếm người
để mà hợp cả Vậy mà chơi cùng
thấy không chơi Liên Minh nhà mình có
chơi giờ Bây giờ mình thấy là liên minh
nó hơi bị nhàm chán so với đôi ta mình
mình đang có điện như thế hết cách các
bạn có thể thử qua rồi lại thì các bạn
sẽ thấy nó sẽ có cái khác nhưng không có
cái nào hay hơn nhưng mà mình đã từng
chơi liên minh vậy chắc mình chán đến
mình rồi mình chơi Liên Minh Hà Lâu rồi
anh cũng phải 565 gì đấy
anh làm sao để học tốt Ok Làm sao để học
tốt bất kỳ cái gì đó thì ra các bạn chị
ở đoạn thực hành nhiều thôi
đừng có xem nhiều lý thuyết quả các bạn
cứ nghĩ là một cái đề bài rồi Các bạn cứ
tham nhũng áp dụng Dần vào ngành lập
trình này của mình ở không nên lý thuyết
quá mà khác với ngành khác
ở DOTA DOTA mình sẽ đánh được mọi vị trí
chứ mít mình không dọn ít à
a tiếp theo là có
cái public này không phải là công khai
máy mình đang dùng cái gì đâu nhé Mà với
máy này em chưa Hôm trước có bạn nói về
cái vụ à thuế vô sinh bị đắt thì mình
thì ra các bạn có thể có thể là các bạn
thể công khai máy mình ra nước ra quốc
gia nghỉ dạy internet để mà người khác
có thể kết nối được vào máy mình nhưng
mà nó bị nhược điểm đó là mỗi khi mà các
bạn ra được ngoài thì có nghĩa là thằng
khác nó vào được các bạn trước khi các
bạn cài thêm một vài cái mật khẩu từ
caro chưa thử vụ đấy rồi nhưng mà chúng
ở một khi mà thằng các bạn đã công khai
để ra ngoài thì chắc chắn nó sẽ có thằng
để nó nó vào được nên là các bạn cũng
nên cân nhắc lại vụ này nó Khánh đi ông
ạ giống kiểu Cái này không phải teamview
nữa cơ một cái này thì rộng rãi cũng
khai cũng khai thằng áo
anh cũng có tài khoản nào có thể vào
được
à à xin code
tôi tôi ghi lại cái câu này để tôi nói
ngắn ngủn mấy ông này đó là cốt như nào
thì quất như vậy đôi khi ở Hồi trước tôi
từng đánh giá các bạn làm cái tài liệu
anh không cần xem các bạn cốt có xe mấy
ông làm word thôi mày ông kể việc chăm
chỉnh cái tài liệu file đấy như nào Đúng
kiểu cốt của ông nói dối như thế ông
không cách này nó không tác nuôi đầu
dòng mà lại không tắm chỉnh nó này bởi
cốt của ông xem nó đúng kiểu như thế
luôn cậu ông không dùng tem luôn ông ông
kiểu hứng lên thì ta và hướng lên thì
dùng cách cốt của ông trong một như một
mớ hỗn độn đúng như cái vuốt của ông vậy
nên thành ra là mấy ông về sau tội đánh
giá mấy ông word mà Mấy ông ngồi căn
chỉnh từng cái từng từng tí một đấy Ghi
cú pháp đi lỗi chính tả các thưởng thức
cẩn thận đấy nhưng tôi khẳng định luôn
cái cốt của cũng cẩn thận như thế
Ê mấy ông về sau tự đánh giá bản thân
mình xem cái câu hỏi đúng không nhé
anh nói chung là cái này nó liên quan
Với cái tính cạnh con người hơn tính
cách con người làm gì đó cẩn thận và cực
kỳ Mị và thưởng cho Suốt nó thì quất nó
sẽ thấy I
em trả lời nói con này à
à à Dùng ra Swift để tính toán công
trước có bạn bảo mình về cái vụ là các
bạn Nếu về cái vụ đặt hàng không ạ mình
cho các bạn xem lại vụ đặt hàng nhé
à à
A Gọi hàng tụi bay mất rồi tôi tạo lại
giỏ hàng nha
Ở đây có tổng tiền thì hôm trước các bạn
bảo lại có bạn bảo là em sẽ tính tổng
tiền này bằng g-speed thậm chí gửi ra
clip này Lên đây b để lưu lại thật là
hôm đấy Mình có nói luôn à mình không
nên đẩy những cái tổng tiền lên để mình
giữ lại Bởi vì a nếu mà tính toán ở bên
bên Klein size sau đó còn lưu lại cái mà
đã đã tính ở bên clan sai thì hoàn toàn
người dùng có thể sửa được cái cái tính
toán đấy để khi mình lưu lại thì sẽ lưu
lại theo cái người dùng đã sửa thì nói
mình sai thế nên bài toán ở đây là các
bạn chỉ cần có thể dùng ra Speed để mà
tính toán thôi đã sử Cái này có để tính
toán là nó cứ cái này có thể tính toán
nó giá ship Tại sao mình khuyên các bạn
có thể tính toán Rocket mà không phải
dùng Peppa như mình đang dùng đây mình
cho các bạn xem nhé
ờ ờ Build này các bạn thấy nó à mình nó
dùng tfp để tính toán Dạo này mình đang
dùng vòng lặp
dùng số lượng nhân với giá sau đó cộng
và tổng sau đó in ra cái tổng này mặc p
các bạn sẽ bảo là cái này thì thế này là
rất là nhanh rồi tốc độ tải trang cái
này chưa đến 1 giây mà thấy đó ngoại
nhưng mà về sau sự ra làm trang web ở
các bạn đẩy lên mạng là kiểu gì nó cũng
phải mất thêm 2 giây liên quan đến tốc
độ mạng nữa sau đó kết hợp việc là FPT
Vì sao các bạn có hệ tình đoàn nhiều hơn
và nặng hơn và trung học có thể mất lên
hơn 3 giây nếu mà các bạn dùng kẹp để
tính toán và Y Na mọi thứ Nếu sẽ tra cho
nên là nó sẽ mất thêm thời gian thay vì
như thế như mình đã nói thì file Pepe nó
có chạy theo cơ chế nào ạ đó khi nó tính
toán nó làm ra hết tất cả mọi thứ rồi Nó
bùng một phát bùn đang từ trang trắng
tinh nó hiển thị ra đồng loạt luôn thời
gian trải nghiệm Thế cụ mới dùng Khiêm
Ấn Độ chợ hoa dây trang trắng tinh dùng
một phát hiển thị ra hết trách nhiệm đấy
không thể tốt trải nghiệm thế nào tốt
thử nghiệm mà các bạn lót được trước cái
gì chị loát sau đó thì hiển thị ra sau
tức là những cái gì không cần mình đoán
các bạn thì chị rằng ra bạn tfp các bạn
hiển thị ra trước còn cái gì tính toán
được các bạn sẽ dùng ra Swift chạy chứng
chính mày khách hàng để tính toàn nốt ra
nốt những cái còn lại thậm chí thằng
Facebook để làm cơ chế khác đồng ý nhiều
không cũng làm có thể nó khác một tí đó
hiển thị trước phải khung của cái tra
ngày trước đấy Sau đó thì dùng ra quýt
để lót dần cái dữ liệu từ BP Gửi về để
in nó ra cái đấy có thể gọi bằng R cũng
được cái đấy thì ông nào ở đây mà biết
tí gì hủy rác đã thử thứ thì nghe thấy
là hiểu rồi nhưng mà đại khá như tôi vừa
nói qua thì các bạn mệt cái cái hướng mà
tôi chỉ ở mấy ông mấy ông ở đây có mấy
ông cậu biết cốt rồi mà Mấy ông sẽ hiểu
gì tôi đó là à tôi có những cái tính
toán không cần phải tính toán p như vừa
rồi mà có thể dùng ra Swift để tính toán
TP chỉ có mang ý nghĩa là kết nối dp và
hiển thị cái đã lấy từ B về thôi còn
việc tính toán xử lý dữ liệu cái gì nó
không có liên quan đến bảo mật cái gì
không liên quan đến việc là kiểu cần che
nó đi xả từ giống như số lượng giá nhân
với số lượng có gì cần phải chè đi đâu
Đúng ngon thì các bạn có để tính toán
bằng g-speed đây trải nghiệm với dùng
Hoàng nhanh hơn người dùng và đưa ra
quyết nó xử lý bất đồng bộ nên nó sẽ gì
Cái này có thể chứa xong cái này dọn
xong rồi nó vẫn là nhanh nhanh hơn TP
rất nhiều FPT từng toán xong hết từ trên
xuống dưới rồi mới ra được cái này nhưng
nó bị trận đều không ạ
tư nhân Như bây giờ thì méo không thể
trải nghiệm người dùng nó khác biệt mấy
vì tôi đang chạy trên lô cổ để nói chưa
đến 1 giây thôi
thứ hai trong những cái mà tôi đang nói
ông có những cái mà nó hơi bị không đúng
trong cái khóa học cơ bản này vì nó hơi
bị Hơi bị kiểu nâng ca một tí đi làm rồi
nhưng mà nhưng mà tôi không Tôi không
thể lưu lại cái này xong rồi để tâm phải
20 cái buổi nữa rồi bắt đầu trả lời được
không phải tự quên thôi
Nên là ông làm mà nghe được Bây giờ tôi
khẳng định luôn là khá tốt những cái lời
khuyên chân
A
giỏ hàng này muốn đổi tiền tệ á về cái
việc tự đổi đến tệ ra đấy lại làm một
cái bài toán nó kiểu các bạn nhân với tỷ
giá có cứ các bạn đấy tỷ giá từ đâu các
bạn một là hot cốt theo cả là nhân với
21.000 ở ngã Nếu mà ra Việt Nam đồng
nóng ạ Nhưng mà nếu và các bạn muốn tỷ
giá chính xác thì các bạn phải luôn gọi
lên cái trang để hồi đấy thì giá đúng
không ạ Vẫn Vân cái thì ra ở cái đấy nó
hơi bị cao siêu quá Mình chưa dậy được à
à À đấy bây giờ nãy giờ lan man nhiều
quá chứ hôm nay được nhắn thôi này nó
tôi mới cho phép mình làm mà mình thế
bây giờ giả sử bây giờ sang bên admin
Hôm nay tôi sẽ dạy các bạn toàn bộ những
cái còn lại của Ben admin con buổi sao
mà thực ra tôi đến bây giờ thôi còn chưa
biết ở Tôi sẽ dạy các bạn cái gì ngờ hôm
nay đúng là tôi sẽ dạy những cái còn sót
lại của bên đề Nami đồng ạ
à à
bộ phim
Ờ thì đầu tiên là khi mà vào bên admin
như thế này thì các bạn thấy là bây giờ
mình cần phải có cái trang đăng nhập chứ
không Mày thì chị ơi Trang chống trơn
như Ai Xui
thằng nào cũng tự ý vào thêm sản phẩm
được đúng ạ thì mình sẽ có khả năng nhập
khi mới vào và tên nó lại Index để khi
mới vào nó nhảy luôn và trắng đăng nhập
không ạ
ở
phòng
đăng nhập thằng nào ạ
à à
ừ ừ
các vì sao đi chơi giáng sinh nhá
từ ngày 25 Ok Nếu buổi sau về đồ án mà
ngoạn thì không chơi bời thì tôi không
quan tâm
10 điểm danh với tốt em với ông rồi mà
tôi không có bạn admin này là sự tôi có
bạn amin tôi sẽ có mã tên email mật khẩu
cấp độ Chắc là Năm Cũ
à à
ừ ừ
ở trung tâm cho ấm
ông trùm chăn cùng người yêu ấm hơn mà
hỗ trợ đâm nhất của mấy ông biết là gì
không chừng 100 thôi ôm ôm không những
ôm người yêu mà
Ừ giờ nó cái này hơi bị tế nhị nhưng mà
chắc là mấy ông đều có người lớn rồi
Không mặc vì ôm nhiều sướng nhất
mà Tại sao tôi nói vụ đấy Ở đây có bé tí
thôi sẽ đăng bài về lợi ích việc không
mặc gì khi đi ngủ
Ừ nếu điều người lớn rồi hỏi trẻ con nó
khẳng định mấy ông xem phim 18 + xem rồi
cho được chưa 18 cộng
à à
Ừ ông và tự nhận trẻ con đây nè
Ừ tôi không nói mấy ông trả Nghiện rồi
nữa chắc là nó phải ông kiểu gì Con xem
nhiều cái chồng con chắc chắn là không
chưa đến tuổi đã xem đấy nên đừng có nói
tôi cậu Nếu ông ngây thơ trong sáng thì
những cái điều đấy Tôi không tin nữa
à à à à
Hồ
Chí Minh
à à
để
tìm hiểu ở đâu Không nói
ông ông nhờ câu đấy nhé tí ông hỏi lại
cậu ấy tôi trả lời chứ ạ
à à thôi sách nói này à
à à
mô tả sự về đăng nhập ngoại bây giờ
đương nhiên là chưa có tài khoản gì mà
mình đăng nhập được cũng tài đấy bọn thì
và luôn
các bạn sẽ không thể bị hack không có
tài khoản đăng nhập
khi nãy sửa Long này mình sẽ đặt tên là
thôi mình là tên admin đi
admin@gmail.com mật khẩu là 123 đấy cấp
độ ở đây dùm mình để poland không tất cả
chị Bình thường sẽ đó đây Super admin
tại xã ép amin này a còng Gmail chấm con
2 3 4 Này mật khẩu level 1 cái làm thì ở
có quyền hơn
I thought ID không được để trống Á xin
lỗi xin lỗi phải gồng mình đã tạo bạn
ngang qua mình không cho nó tự động tăng
rồi
sau khi ở để tự động tăng ngày các bạn
sẽ làm sẽ bị lỗi kia có bạn không không
để nó là rapper Lucky
Brand men's rồi
Ê mày mới sử dụng 30 giây rồi
cái bạn cần để đây các bạn phải để nó nó
là phải kia trước như thế này cho để nó
phải mê tín trước sau đó cả mọi người để
tự động tăng nằm mới chạy
xe máy tự động Tài
ở đó thì mới được bởi vì cột tự động
tăng của cuộc đời bắt buộc phải là khóa
chính
sau đó với rồi Insert
họ đậu xanh
à à
hình ảnh Copy lại có lệnh vậy
anh xóa code ID nè Ơ sao lại đi
à cậu
anh nói đùa
có phải nó sẽ ra ngay
Xin chào Phương lịch nãy giờ mới thấy
Ừ Ok giờ mình sẽ có admin
mật khẩu 123
Em có phải xử lý này đóng ạ Dạo này làm
nhanh nhá Dạo này sẽ là mình sẽ kết nối
để B
ở bên này
cứ nói lấy
email và mật khẩu về à
à à
a
password
đây mình sẽ có ông có ông hội trước và
bị nhầm một này ông ấy cho bạn cái câu
Insert đây luôn sẽ mỗi lần đăng nhập và
phát một ngày mới mình cười ấy biết
người đăng ký
sẽ lexar for admin gì nhỉ là tên amin
amin foma
halliwell tôi đủ à Nó bị lúa rồi à
anh
một ngày thật ra chúng ta chỉ có tầm có
người ấy chứ không bảo chỉ một tiếng
tỉnh táo ơi anh như là tôi vừa nãy dùng
một tiếng tình ta cho cái việc khác rồi
thì nó bị lúa rồi à
Ừ
cái này trả về dữ liệu này thì mình sẽ
có đôi sút ở đây
và mình cần lấy thằng đầu tiên là sử
mình cần lấy thằng đầu tiên từ Paris á
không cho không trước khi lấy cái này
thì mình sẽ ít phải đã If My Cloud 5 pro
à à
- sốt
Ê hồi trước mình từng giải quyết giải
thích về cái vụ khi nào dùng đi quay cho
dùng include đấy Hai cái nó khác nhau
một cái túi có ai đó sẽ là khi mà xa sai
cái file gì đó thì nó sẽ
sau khi mà sai đường dẫn phải không cần
tải thì cốt rồi nó ngừng luôn còn
ingrowth thì kể cả cho dù không che được
file thì cốt ở dưới vẫn sẽ chạy nhà nó
nó sẽ bị sai khi mà cốt được rồi đấy nó
chạy dựa theo cái này đúng ạ Anh các bạn
nên dùng đi qua nhiều hơn là giống như
Plus
à à
Ê mày không kêu đang bị ý tôi đang chào
ai
nhé giờ rồi
Mấy ông chị tinh tế những cái đấy thì
chết
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok
nói chung cái này nhiều nó bằng bằng một
cách làm trị trả về một cái quạt thì
mình mới Mày lấy dữ liệu ra rồi Mình lưu
ở trong bêtông ạ trong season không ạ
thì bạn nhớ việc mình sẽ lưu lại những
gì ông Sơn không ạ
Alo alo tập trung là mấy ông sẽ lưu lại
thì ông Sun Ah
em ở đâu không đoạn này nữa không em nữa
thì cái gì mình sẽ điều hướng quay trở
về trang chủ rồi đây mình sẽ cứ hết đồ
vô cái chân Quay lại trang đăng nhập
thôi kèm theo một cái gì đó hoặc kèm
theo alo chúng sinh tùy ý
để lưu lại gì trong sẽ phần nào tập
trung tập trung mạnh
à à
và những người bạn kia nó phải lưu em
level chuẩn rồi ai đi này level này nó
còn lên nữa
chị đã lưu lại nêm để mà luôn hiển thị
ra đó ngoại hiệu season lưu lại ID để mà
Luôn luôn lấy từ season ra cái ID của
người đang đăng nhập lại biết được cả lo
nhập nhoạng không không không cần read
your name email đâu vì mình không thường
xuyên dùng là lâu đấy Mình không cần lại
luôn thì lại người dùng gửi email mày là
gì đó không cân
à
mà lưu lại level làm gì để mà tí làm cái
Kim Quyên lắm chị ạ Chị có ăn Minh được
vào đây và Superman không được vào đây
Mình sẽ lưu lại những cái như đấy
đó Khi mà Song Ngư này xong các bạn có
thể
dùng cái Trần ngại xanh root như này trở
lại
gì nó chửi Hử chủ tịch chéo ngay cơ thử
xem có trạm nhé
anh rút rồi Index chấm pp trong đó chắc
chắn cũng được
rồi axit ở đây để kết thúc luôn câu lệnh
này hãy tránh việc ở nhảy xuống tới hết
đồ rồi đấy
à à ô hay vợ tôi thử chạy thương ở ở đó
lập tức anh nhảy sang giao diện của
Admin Đông ạ Đây giao diện chung của My
ạ bây giờ sự là mọi người thấy là tôi
chưa kiểm tra quyền gì cả Bây giờ ra sự
copy cái đường Linh này vào nha nó vẫn
vào được và bên Nga ẩn danh nhỉ thức là
không đăng nhập được ngoan vẫn vào được
thì mình cần mình sẽ tạo ra một cái file
để mà khi mà
300 lưu lại vào mạng thôi Cứ phải lấy ra
từng mảnh được ít ai làm thế á à mình
mình à
chú ý bạn là làm mảng hai chiều đúng
không không không Mình không cần phải
làm thế đâu
Thì bây giờ đầu tiên là mình muốn nữa
anh luôn kiểm tra luôn kiểm tra ở bất kỳ
file nào biến amin là kiểm tra là người
dùng đã đăng nhập hay chưa ngoại thì thứ
nhất ở đây là các bạn nên nhớ một điều
là hôm trước mình làm cho thằng khách
hàng đăng nhập các bạn xem lại nhé
khi khách hàng đăng nhập
Ừ thì nó mạnh lưu lại em rất giận cũng
có ai đi vào còn nên có rồi không ạ hết
thứ khác biệt giữa việc là admin gửi
khách hàng ở đây nó có thêm mỗi level
nên là mình thường ai kiểm tra theo
level đủ rồi thì mình sẽ yêu anh kiểm
tra như thế ngã ở Sistar đây sau kiểm
tra nếu mà có level tớ cảm chuyện là An
Min đã đăng nhập thì sẽ cho truy cập vào
đây ông ạ thì đây mình sẽ là tạo ra một
file ở ngoài cùng đi mình không ai tạo
pha ngoài cùng sẽ như phải ở đây nó là
file check amin Lucky nữa ngăn chặn pp
phải là chuyện đơn giản thôi bạn này
start
chợ hoa cà như tôi đã nói với file lại
inplus ở khá nhiều Phai các bạn có thể
sử xác ở ngoài rồi chèn phát này nhưng
bởi vì pha này luôn Nằm đầu những cái
file kia nên tôi cứ sát ở đây cũng được
không sao sau đó đi sân à Ít ký xét và
ngược lại là nếu không có desciption
tại level thì mình sẽ hết đồ
độ chấm chấm súc ra ở đâu lâu cái chân
đã rồi chấm chấm suốt ra nhưng đ.tp tại
sao các bạn thắc mắc ở vụ mình lại chấm
chấm suốt ra bởi các bạn để ý kĩ là nọ
Khiêm mình vào những cái thư mục con như
thế này thì nó mới văng ra ngoài không ạ
thư mục con như thế này mình vàng ra đấy
điểm lợi thế mình chấm giống Suga nó sẽ
luôn tăng ra ngoài em mình hết thử bên
ẩn danh này tại ra đương nhiên các bạn
thấy vẫn thấy gì chưa chai này đây mình
kiểm tra nhé
À mình sẽ đi qua đây này
A xem.su Ốc ra check amin
in
pp
đó phân ra ngoài đồng hóa
ở đây chắc chắn sẽ không bao đấy được
nữa
ở season pass và file con ếch cho ông bị
kiểm tra gì thật là rất khó thì mà bây
giờ sự nỡ mình vào file con nít như thế
này người dùng và file crack này cứ bạn
chẳng sao ngày dùng này đúng là không
lên được phép bày file lại nhưng mà rồi
vào file này đưa nó thì trống trơn không
thành không ảnh hưởng gì bảo mật cả cũng
nó là đúng là ok Nó thể tạo thêm à
có một cái Mở truy vấn nữa nhưng mà
nhưng mà kiểu nó nó không bị ảnh hưởng
lắm và khi mà các bạn sang mô hình cái
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ hạn chế
việc và nó sẽ dụng hp Asus thì chắc chắn
không có quyền truy cập hẳn vào với thư
mục ngoài luôn đấy tính sau
Ừ chị nha bố ru rú lên vì
đi đá bóng
anh bạn tôi nói tôi ghét Xem bóng đá vì
thế một đứa số loạn hết lên kia mình
đang tập trung cái gì đó
anh nói thế thôi nhưng dài tôi bảo tôi
đã không còn thành kiếm về bóng đá làm
nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ ok đấy vừa rồi á An đấy tôi còn gợi ý
thêm mấy ông mấy ông thầy có cái biểu
tượng đây 202 đúng không Nếu biết Đố mày
ông đoán được
áo bóng đá được à cái á mình cái biểu
tượng cái dấu chấm như thế này nó là gì
biết biết được
Ừ tự nhiên toàn bộ phát ở đây Tôi có mỗi
vài file có cái chấm như thế này
ông ngoại biết nói gì
à à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn tên là đúng rồi nghĩa là
file file đã có thay đổi file có thay
đổi file mới của bên A bên ít thằng bên
get nó đang nhận diện được file của tôi
có phải fan mới để bây giờ tôi giờ sự
thôi đầy cái cốt lên thì đây phải cho
mấy ông xe web cơ bản đóng lại
ở đó thì đây là những cái file đã
thấy dấu cộng này những file mới này Đây
là những file đã thay đổi này đó xinh
không ạ
ở
trong có giá trị mà nó ngọn các bạn làm
việc với ít nhiều các bạn thế Kiểu cái
năng kịp nó cũng rất à chuyên nghiệp
Ừ ok ở đây đi ỉa chèn ở bên cô Đắc này
là các bạn phải chèn vào trong mọi file
khác cái file check check này là mình sẽ
copy nhé
the mentalist này có phải chè đó à
bộ phim sex coppia
ở shopee ra ngoài thôi
Ok này form có pin cách mà copy ra ngoài
khi Đảng ta sẽ enter nó xuống như thế
này rồi copy hơn
khi
họ ở đây ok này
gì tôi copy luôn cả cái enter a luôn à
ừ ừ
khi flash xong này nhìn đất sao không
Này Insert
cơ sở đây Thế ra ở đây nhận được thì ra
nhìn trâu vẻ hơi khó chịu một tí cái
đóng cho mở các thư hơi khó chịu gì Xóa
bớt đi
à à
Ừ Ok thế là xong Còn bên còn bên nhà sản
xuất thì hôm trước tôi còn nói đó là
super admin thì không
Ừ thì mới được phép truy cập ở đây còn
admin là thằng nhân viên bình thường
không được phép truy cập vào thì vừa
mình sẽ cải tạo 1 file nữa 1 file nữa
nhé mình sẽ tạo một vài nữa nó check
Superman ạ ạ
anh admin cũng được và các bạn ghi vừa
thực ra có nhiều bạn không Để ý kỹ chữ S
mà bé quá cho bạn sẽ bị nhầm nữa ghi hẳn
chết xúc với amin nó rõ hơn thì cái này
không thì ông giản là kiểm tra được đăng
nhập nữa mà các bạn có thể cho nó luôn
như thế này à
ý là vừa kiểm tra việc như này và mình
sẽ kiểm tra thêm
Ừ anh em à ờ ờ season đầu tiên kiểm tra
Nó tồn tại nhá rồi Kiểm tra thêm là
level phải bằng bằng 1
ở Bảng 1 nhàdat cho
con để chắc chả nó số một con có cách
tắt hơn đắt hơn nữa bọn nó
ở đó là kiểm tra nha tôi Chị ở mấy ông
nhanh MV
à à
cách tôi tôi sẽ tách nó làm hai dòng và
và chú thích nó lại cho mấy ông dễ nhìn
dễ hình dung nhé Nếu mà không có
tin không có level này hoặc hoặc này
nếu mà do season
tại level
khác 1
Ê bà tôi hết rút ngắn nó lại như thế này
thì kệ em tin này nó tác dụng làm gì em
tin này nó vừa kiểm tra là trống tất cả
nếu không có cái này nó vừa kiểm tra
đúng nghĩa là trống thứ cảm ơn chị à Cái
này nó bằng không Level của mình nó là
gì ở đây vào chỗ có không hoặc một nghĩa
là nếu mà có level nhưng mà lên Một Bằng
Không thì cũng không được cũng không
được phép đầu nhọn cũng không được phép
vào bên sovremenny đó đấy cái rất là hay
thì nó sẽ gộp hai cái câu mày một cái
như thế này Ừ mình thích cái hàm em thì
ở điểm đấy kiểm tra khá tiện lắm chế
thằng MT ở kiểm tra sâu được thần access
nó phải kiểm tra từng cấp từng cấp của
cái thằng Mạnh một chiều vậy à
Ừ mạng 23 chiều nó phải kiểm tra từ
ngoài vào trong còn MT ở kiểm tra toàn
bộ được vì nhớ Thế
đi xe hai người đó Nhã Okay đây thì
thì mình sẽ đi qua Fi này thôi
thì mình sẽ có mình sẽ copy cái wai nhé
ạ
à à Khi mà mình sẽ đổi nó chết Giúp Ami
này à
cho nó giống cái dấu thăng nhưng mà đúng
ơi nó cũng giống dấu thăng vừa vì bạn
chất ở nó cũng là pho chu mỏ nhọn chú
phone Thì đó nếu mà nó khác với cái
Ừ nó khác về axit các bạn đừng có bị
đánh Đồng nó sang thành ý xét nhé MT nó
không phải nó khác với cái
với cảnh ngược lại đi xe đâu nhé bởi vì
access và kiểm tra Nó tồn tại không thôi
Nên là nếu mà ngược lại với ý xét nó nếu
giờ sự là level Vừa bằng không ạ Đây hồ
bằng không thì thì vẫn là có giá trị
không nó vẫn tính là có giá trị đúng ạ
xz Nó chỉ kiểm tra về cái ít về kiểm tra
trường hợp nó nun nó không tồn tại thôi
các bạn nghĩa vụ đấy không Nếu về vụ nhu
nó không cầm để mình giành lại bụng nôn
vừa không nghe
ở làng lại về bài Thất tình thi
em nghĩ xem nó kiểm tra là bạn đã từng
có người yêu chưa không quan tâm mình
lượt là bạn đã
mà bạn có nghĩa rồi nhưng chia tay còn
MT thì nó ngược lại Nó là kiểu MT ấm chị
hiện tại bạn có nhiều khi không nghĩa là
không quan tâm quá khứ của bạn như thế
nào đó nhà
3000 nhá
thì bạn là như thế này đúng không Ý bạn
là có thể dùng Bách kiệm tắt kiểu nghe
được không ạ
anh em mình sẽ đăng ký kết đây nhá Đi
bạn là ngược lại nha được đúng không ạ
anh đúng không
Ừ ừ đúng nếu bạn sẽ dừng hợp và level
các bạn bằng không mà có bạn ngược lại
đúng những cái này nó sẽ bị sai điểm là
nếu mà giờ không có cả lấy bồ rồi sao
cái đoạn này sẽ bị lỗi đoạn này nó sẽ bị
lỗi Đồ ngoại
Ừ nếu có hiểu gì đâu mà Bởi vì nếu không
có level để chắc chắn nó sẽ báo lỗi đấy
này không tin hệ level thế là ông không
chơi cách này ở đây được
mà mày ông liên hệ dùng hạn như thế này
à à
Ừ ông kia chơi trò cả hỏi chấm hỏi chấm
rồi bằng bằng á Tôi chưa thử cái vụ đấy
bây giờ nhưng mà không không không ai
chơi Tôi chơi chưa nghĩ có người dùng
cần hỏi chấm hỏi chấm Bằng rồi sợ
à Xong rồi so sánh kiểu như thế
à à
Anh nhìn cái đoạn cốt để phức tạp hóa
tôi thấy cái đoạn code này trong hạnh
phứctạp Tôi không muốn thử ở đâu nhìn
cái này cho đỡ giản mà cho ngắn đơn giản
hơn nhiều nhớ đương nhiên là nếu mà mới
với người mới như ông đoạn này nó có thể
phải biết về một vài hàng mới và không ạ
ạ
Ừ ok hơi dài dòng tí rồi tiếp tục nhé
ờ ờ
anh em mình bấm với nhà sản xuất này
được được để hơi sai đấy Thử lại nhé
hàng ôtô chưa chắc hết anh xin lỗi
em nghe nói hơi lan man quá phải lan man
cũng cũng cũng đúng chậm đâm mà chẳng
qua là bị mình hơi bị
anh Tốn hơi nhiều thời gian đi
em vẫn vẫn đúng không Không có lỗi raman
nó bị thừa mình thấy nãy giờ mình không
không nói thử ở
nó như này để ấn vào này sẽ xong ra lắm
nhỉ Ok chưa rồi mình bắt buộc mình sẽ
phải mình sẽ phải vào bằng Superman à
à à
Ừ nó
ừ ừ
ở đây đây thực Hà vừa rồi mình nói qua
cho các bạn về bên kiểm tra quyền bây
giờ mình sẽ nói thêm nốt cả nữa của bên
emminh cho xong cái này thời gian nó vẫn
là dài không biết là các bạn theo kịp
không nhớ thời gian bây giờ mình học bao
lâu nhỉ đi học từ
ở ga mình học cũng cũng được mới có được
nửa tiếng rồi em mình sẽ nói tiếp nha
nghĩa là video mà mày vẫn thể lên này
hay tiền đấy
Đó là mình sẽ dạy các bạn về cái việc là
em nói sao bây giờ vẫn vào được Vinamilk
mà nhìn trông kẻ vàng Da thì vẫn vào
được
ở lại rút này vẫn vào được bé amin với
mình sẽ dạy các bạn về bên quản lý đơn
hàng xem đơn hàng xem đơn hàng là đớn
hèn chi tiết đều ngoại và xem đơn đã rồi
còn duyệt đơn nữa
ở đầu tiên là có cái Menu này
à à
cha mẹ quản lý đơn hàng này đây này à
Ừ nó bấm ở đây thì sẽ cân ừ ừ
anh tặng new folder order
thế này nó đang bị à Không biết tại sao
là tự nhiên nào Anh hãy về bên A khách
hàng như thế này ông ạ
ở viện sao
Ở đây có 1 file ở đây thì ngơ à
à à
Có phải đây vừa nãy hình nhận à Đúng là
xóa cái rút đi nghệ vào ô tô
xã hội chưa biết tại sao vừa rồi nó nghỉ
ngõ đời như thế không ở thư mục nó nhảy
sang cái file Index tộc
Ừ chắc là do cấu hình của thằng Lara
Gold nó chỉnh gì đó phía thử xem trả lại
Xem vụ đấy nên thôi đã Cứ khỏe bài toán
đã tự mình sẽ có Index 1.tp này
sang Tây Mua lô này
anh
ở đây có được như là pp
out
connector pp này
select from order này à
khi
bé đầu tiên tôi cho mấy ông xem về bên A
a min order trước đã
Em đang ở đâu này mình cần in ra toàn bộ
những đơn đã có là bị lỗi tạm xóa đi này
Ừ anh sẽ in an toàn bộ đơn đang có đúng
không ạ Mình sẽ đi ra trông như thế nào
có đây đi này có số 10 đi mình đội nó
thành thông tin của người đã đạt đồng
loạt Tức là sao mình sẽ phải nối bạn có
SM sau đó thì lấy thông tin người đã đặt
mình in nó ra sau đó mình sẽ có tên
người nhận số điện thoại người nhận
thông tin nhận tại khá thế xa tất của
mình Mình sẽ đổi từ không rảnh của số ở
đó nữa trở thành một cái chữ gì đâu anh
Nghĩa không Nó là mới đặt ở Ngạn 1 Sẽ
như nào đó cho hiển thị thời gian thời
gian nhìn lại các bạn cũng nên hiển thị
sao cho đẹp nữa các bạn sẽ gọi format nó
thành số cho dễ nhìn đôi khi các bạn ơi
7 cái thời gian là lên trên đầu nó dễ
nhìn thấy nó cho họ không nên có cái gì
ông B có lại anh chỉ đúng như thế thì
thì người dùng trải nghiệm người dùng
rất là tệ nó ngoạn có phải bị sao cho dễ
nhìn thẳng phía tiền tệ này các bạn hiển
thị ra kẹo phẩy nhìn xấu hàng đơn vị do
đẹp cũng được anh lại có rất nhiều cách
để các bạn là
anh ở đây thì đây sẽ có mã này đây sẽ có
thời gian này
ra đặt đây sẽ có là
thông tin mới nhận này
không tin người à
người đặt không ạ
Và cũng chị nữa Ở đây có trạng thái này
à
Ồ
thông Tiên ơi à
anh ở đây mình sẽ thật là cậu chứ vấn
machii Paris con knack này à
em bị sốt à
anh
ở đây như tôi vừa nói thì nó là cần kết
nối em bạn có Summer do mày có sờ mờ để
mà lấy thông tin người đặt sẽ roi
summer
chấm ID bằng order chọn customer đi này
thế này
Ừ
anh sẽ cho đôi ếch tại nhà à
anh ở đây nhá các bạn nên lưu ý một tí ở
đây khi mình cho này bảo có sờ mờ Nhưng
mình ở từng nói thì hay đi này đây mình
thụ eid dọa sẽ thấy nó bị lỗi này
Có
ai đi làm xa hoặc 5 hãy đi này không
phải đi under mày đi này Đi của cô cm
mình lấy thừa Cột từ bạn có sờ mờ thằng
nó bị ghi đè lên
cách tốt nhất là mình sẽ không dùng sét
sao mà mình sẽ phải mình lấy thông tin
của toàn bộ đời thì đúng nhưng mà
customer mình sẽ chỉ lấy một vài thông
tin thôi mình sẽ đầy nên nó này là gì
nữa lấy á
Em
email thật cũng được thường là phone
number này
và Atlat nữa chẳng ngại là sự kiểu đập
cửa cái thằng đặt Nếu là sự thằng nghiện
mới không nhận đúng mà anh ấy
chú
ý là ID này ai đi rồi mới đúng này thời
gian đặt mình sẽ là
phát đúng không
Chúng ta đặt
thông tin người nhận thông tin người
nhận thì mình sẽ in nó trong dạng kiểu
enter xuống dòng đi
cái chỗ ở đây là đâu ếch tại à
a baby support này
đây này
ở đây sẽ là
phone VSIP này vào đây sẽ là At last
Supper
xuống dòng nhà cho từng Minh
hi vọng toàn hệ bộ nằm trong cục này lại
tương tự Thế thì sẽ có nêm
a phone number
à mà có Acnes
thông tin người nhận thông tin người đặt
đó cho nó mình đến trạng thái
trạng thái ở đây như mình đã nói bảo là
mình sẽ ít em ở đây mình sẽ ít lợi ích
Tại sao tất
bằng bằng không
tức à
ai dám chịu mở mình sẽ cho ở đây là
người đặt ạ
Ừ
ông kia anh gọi đi mày cái tiếp mà đôi
khi phải xem lại ngôn ngữ ai xem lại P
của bạn ấy đang dùng là phiên bản bao
nhiêu nữa nha
các bạn có thể dùng xích cây ở đây này
Nó không dùng led kích tây ở đây cũng
anh Ừ mình có thể dung tích cây đấy cho
nhanh nhé á
a dola x tại status đỡ phải bỏ đi Gọi
lại sau tất không này mình sẽ chôn là
mới đặt nghe chẳng
ở đây một là đã đặt đã duyệt anh ạ
và hai là đã hủy em ạ hoa -1 Tùy các bạn
ạ
Từ ngày ông địa nói hàng mới nói pp7 tự
nhiên bạn nào cài pp 5.6 cười
a
patrol LX tại
Ồ thông Tiền Toto Price ngay
Ừ ok ở đây ở mới xem kiểu cơ bản của một
cái đơn nhưng mình muốn xem chi tiết của
đơn này thì mình sẽ có cái nút để xem
chi tiết và thận chiến nút duyệt vào nút
hủy đơn cũng có đây sẽ xem này
Ê bà đây sẽ là sửa
mình sẽ có thêm hai cái cột đây một cái
nốt diệt nốt ruồi ở đây
A và các bạn thể xem rồi các bạn với Gia
Huy cũng được
ở đây sẽ ra à
cách tải nút xem thì bạn chất béo ngậy
Thế là nhảy sang trang web khác để xem
này
chị
xem này
hack ép này mình sẽ nhận đến đó đi theo
em ạ TPP chỗ ngồi ai đi bằng EXO x tại
ID
ở như thế này Bấm vào để xem chi tiết
của một đơn nghe cũng về đúng là đúng ạ
Đấy file này mình sẽ
Ê ee kết cái này lại được này tạo một
file
à à
a a file này nãy giờ mình còn quên chưa
chèn thêm cái á
em kiểm tra quyền đấy Mình quên đấy mình
đây sẽ FPT đây kiểm tra Quyền à à
à à
có
thêm một cái kiểm tra quyền để lỡ cho
sắc này
à à
em kiểm tra thì amin là đồ không cần
Superman nó
anh ở đây đầu tiên là mình cần à
a ghi cầu SQL này cái bảng này trọn bộ
Xóa đi đã
chưa bao giờ không đúng nữa
a
Kotex vào đây mình sẽ là tiên mình cần
lấy à ID của order về đã cho get ID này
à
em
đặt tên là oder đi rồi cho chọn đi Sau
đó thì sẽ rách sao form
để mình cần làm là gì mình xem order cô
đắt có
dưỡng yêu đời đi để rồi nối từ caller ID
sang bảng cô đắp để mà lấy thông tin của
cô đắp đó sau đó đi ý hiển thị quantity
số lượng các thứ nó ạ em mình về mình sẽ
làm là
I
wander Của Đất Này
Where I ordered
bằng
đó là Oh Daddy này mà mình chalkboard
on của đất trời mai đi bằng order for
them board-id
ngày này
ạ Và bây giờ mình ra mình không cần mã
nữa mình có thể có cái bên à Thì mình có
ở bên Nam
Cho mình hỏi có phải bên hiển thị Cái
này là ổn nhất này ạ
anh em tôi thấy là có bạn nó rất là
giống có ảnh tên sản phẩm giá số lượng
tổng tiền nó giống hệt mà đúng không ạ
Các bạn copy bên này là nghe nhỉ
Em
nói như này chị mình chỉ đổi lại những
cái gì
đây mình sẽ có đổi ở đây là cây sút
thành đội lợi ích như thế này
cho ex photo name price
em không có thay đổi số lượng nữa không
ạ số lượng kiểu cố định rồi
anh không thấy tôi làm mọi thứ có pin
nhanh không ạ Đấy tổng tiền các thứ thứ
mình sẽ có biến tổng ở trên này tổng
tiền bằng không
Khi
mà mình thấy nàng á
xin lỗi Xem Tại sao lâu thế nào đối tại
xong
299 lỗi
I
ask có bạn ngay nữa kê ở đây không còn
bên ai đi nữa này không còn ra không còn
xóa nữa bỏ đi này Đó ok rồi đây Mình chỉ
cần in với tổng tiền ở cuối H1 tổng tiền
đơn này là xong rồi Chỗ
do xăm
Tôi không biết mấy ông nhà nhưng mà tôi
dậy
vì tính Tôi lười nhưng tôi dậy với anh
lắm
chị sẽ chấm chấm súc ra này
Ừ ok chưa nghèo để copy code rất nhanh
đó mấy ông còn cái vụ mà ấn duyệt một
đơn Hủy một đơn đấy mẹ con sẽ chỉ nhanh
không mấy ông
ở Tân nhanh thôi ông ạ
anh ở đây mấy ông nói chung ở đây xem
được thông tin của một đơn rồi này so
với ông thể quay lại để ấn Tuyệt quá Hủy
một đơn chẳng hạn thế Thì mình sẽ
Ừ tôi cốt chồng vậy Vừa nói vừa cốt
trông có vẻ hơi chậm Nhưng mà tôi gõ
được gánh anh ấy đúng không ạ gõ Khánh
Anh ấy hi vọng để không theo kịp
anh ở đây Tôi có duyệt ạ
Thật ra diệt với Hủy nó khác nhau điểm
gì giống như gái vụ mà thay đổi số lượng
ý cho duyệt với bản chất nó đỡ update
update Cái tình trạng đơn chẳng qua thay
đổi cái số status của nó thành công ấy
một hạ thì mình đây là sự mình có một
cái đơn giản làm update này có ai đi rồi
mình thêm thay cho nó nữa
sau Tết là bằng mấy là sự bằng một tất
cả chị duyệt còn bằng hai rất là hủy là
nói dối không ạ Rồi cái file update này
mình sẽ
để tạo ra nói
a&p này
ô oh Daddy đúng ạ là đô la get ID này
xong rồi lại đi quay kết nối này
đi
soi cầu FeO sẽ bằng update
order set status
ở bảng alo nói chuyện được rồi sao tất
nữa
à à
ở bảng donis Where ID bằng
id ngay sáng lạn thế xong rồi Nhắn mãi
chưa ạ
em
gái mình chạy thử nhé mình thở tại trang
này ở đây hai nút chưa Duyên hàng nó
diệt nhưng mà thật ra một mùa trong
những cái nốt về nuôi hay ai nút duyệt
ủy các bạn Thể định balo là số 5.000 cho
nó đẹp không đi đây thì có giao diện với
ông vẫn thấy xấu Nếu Vậy chị ngại giao
diện này không quan tâm giao diện nóng
lạnh ấn duyệt này
xe tải
anh quay lại đây này quay lại miễn phải
quay lại đôi khi không còn tại sao nó
biến anh đã rượt thôi ok này nhưng mà ở
đây lý Quỹ một tí nhá Khi mà đã được rồi
các bạn phải ấn cái nút duyệt và ẩn nút
vị đi không nói chuyện diệt rồi Thiều
Huy và được ra Duyệt rồi không được ấn
nút duyệt lại nữa đúng không ạ
Ừ thì mấy ông phải ẩn nó đi và ấn bằng
cách nào mà không sẽ ít theo cái đoạn mà
này để ẩn nút đi này không ít cái sa tế
ớt là bằng mấy thì sẽ nói đi Tôi đang
nói như thế để cho có việc nếu làm không
biết ông có hết cốt của tôi về hết cái
mà làm đương nhiên là hôm bảo vệ đồ án
Tôi sẽ dạy mẹ tôi sẽ khỏi ông câu của nó
ăn hơn rất nhiều câu Họ luôn Nếu anh
cũng nghĩ rằng đi đấy đại khái Hôm nay
tôi vừa chạy qua nốt toàn bộ những cái
con có thể Sao lại của bên emminh không
biết là các bạn còn thắc mắc thêm cái gì
thêm tính năng gì đó thì hỏi thêm tôi
không thì buổi hôm sau với tôi sẽ dậy
sâu hơn người cách viết tài liệu để mày
Ông viết dần tài liệu nữa
Ừ rồi tuần sau thì chắc là hết gần như
là xong các tính năng cơ bản đấy thì
thôi sẽ chuyển qua những cái tính năng
nâng cao thì chắc là cũng có nhưng mà
dần dần dần nâng nâng cái mức độ khó lên
ngày làm gì ở khó những cái mức độ dễ
thì tôi sẽ mà qua trước thậm chí là tôi
còn phải dậy từ Israel Nếu có sự có
nhiều nhóm quan tâm nên là nói cho Thứ 7
này tôi sẽ thử hỏi tất cả các nhóm Thứ
bảy này cần mấy ông tặng bỏ buổi đi Noel
đi sơ đồ án Hồi trước tôi dậy à Hồi
trước thấy tôi bảo đó là có vụ án thì
người yêu cũng phải bị sau đi tất cả mọi
thứ làm đồ án đã xác định quên ăn quên
ngủ thì đừng có quên người yêu quên hết
thì thế mới làm đoán thế mới gọi thực sự
là tập trung vào công việc được không ạ
Ừ thì thì mình mình sẽ hướng dẫn người
viết em ở bến xe khóa sau bạn nhé họ sau
này thì à
ăn mì ý đi mọi người không làm việc thì
mọi người nên ế
Ừ quan điểm của tôi là phải làm làm việc
làm việc phải làm việc chơi chơi học học
chuyện yêu đương là việc của yêu đúng
lúc làm việc Tôi tập trung mắt giống như
là bạn nhà đang ngồi gió hú bóng đá ngay
bên cạnh hai giáo cũ bất cái gì bên cạnh
cô quan tâm làm việc làm việc đi
Ừ
thì ạ nói chung à
Ừ thứ bảy này tôi sẽ hỏi qua các bạn để
các bạn xem các bạn thích bầu bầu gọi là
bình chọn bầu cày nên làm những cái tính
năng gì Nhà em với ông nghĩ trước đi các
bạn thì tôi sẽ hướng dẫn dân tất cả các
nhóm và tôi cũng sẽ không đăng cốt lên
mà hướng dẫn qua thì mấy ông địa dịch
mình phải làm lại xong rồi Sửa lại theo
phong cách của mấy ông
Âm Nhạc Ừ ok
Ừ
đúng rồi quên mọi thứ được đừng quên làm
quen làm thành một đứa có dụng mất thì
một đứa ăn hại mua dụng
Ở nhà sửa người yêu mình không không nói
không có ý gì là sự cảm cho gái nó người
yêu mình vô dụng rồi thì mình phải có
hữu dụng như càng yêu mình vô dụng ham
chơi rồi mình cũng ham chơi theo nó thì
hai đứa vô dụng yêu nhau ạ Thế thì xã
hội đi xuống mất ông ạ Tôi chỉ mong
những cái con người cầu tiến yêu nhau
Tôi không mong những con người
anh không có tiền mua dụng yêu nhau
Chúng tôi sinh con đợi cái đất nước này
sẽ đi về đâu Thì kiểu thế
làm ăn quá Vừa nãy có một ông vừa nãy
hỏi tôi câu gì nhá Tao quên mất ta kiếm
người yêu ở đâu đúng không
ừ ừ
anh kiếm kiếm người yêu ở đâu thì thực
ra tội từng nói qua mày Ông rồi đó là
mấy ông phải xác định được người yêu
mình là
rất nhiều Mình là đối tượng như thế nào
cứ tưởng ra sự mới ông và con người của
boy hư hỏng nhưng béo phải chọn nơi họ
cứ hỏi mà kiếm đúng ạ Nếu phải chọn sẽ
lành mạnh được mà ngược lại là thế nếu
mà mếu và con người lãng mạng kiểu kiểu
dạng là một sách kiểu như tôi dân trí
thức thì miếu phải kiếm ở những nơi kiểu
những vẫn trí trúc thường ai đi ông ạ
Ông không ông già sử của tôi là một Nói
chung là cũng cũng đúng cái việc là ông
ông là trà sữa một miếng thủ lên ạ Ông
muốn có bạn gái một game thủ ông phải
đến quán net kiểu thế
Ừ nhưng mà thấy là nó nó có bị Hơi nhược
điểm của gì đó là sự Ông là người hư ông
ở người hướng nội ông thích ở nhà bạn sẽ
thích ở nhà vui vì mình thấy hai đứa
không phải gặp nhau nhưng mà ờ
Ừ nhưng mà Ok nếu giờ sửa hai đứa thích
ở nhà thôi thì thì kiểu gì bạn kia cũng
phải dùng Facebook như thế nào không ạ
tôi vào rồi gặp nhau ngoài đời rồi đôi
khi các bạn ngại dạng ngại bắt chuyện
lắm đây là các bạn nên tìm qua Facebook
hạn thậm chí nếu bế tắc hơn Tìm có tím
đỡ được nhưng nhưng mà
các bạn tìm với Facebook thì
như tôi hồi trước tôi từng nói đó là mấy
ông à
cô để ý xem là những cái người mà mình
thích từ chính những cái test mà mình
Thượng này thích xem người ta từ bình
luận này xem người ta thậm chí à tôi bảo
tôi kiếm từ những người đã thích cái bài
đăng này đã tương tác phải ra người tôi
một con người thích hả hay là tôi sẽ tìm
những cái bạn thả haha Thả tim theo thay
vì thả mỗi cái like kiểu lạnh lùng vô
nghĩa Tôi sẽ tìm những người cần thế bởi
vì những người như thế lại thường ai có
tính cách nó nổi trội hơn tí rất phù hợp
với tôi hơn những người thả lai cho có
tôi thấy Á tìm cách có khi không hợp với
tôi
Anh đấy Anh thấy qua rồi quay tôi hướng
dẫn qua vài cái
mấy cái phải trả phí Ngô mấy ông muốn
tham gia mới khóa học vậy ạ
ở biển quán net mấy bạn có nhiều đi cùng
nhá ông ông đi Còn nick nào ấy còn nét
đôi đi cho khẳng định mấy bạn gái độc
thân ở lại
đi đái mấy ông cứ bi quan như thế rồi
tìm không đúng đổi không đúng chỗ rồi
mấy ông lại cảm thấy suy nghĩ về tắt về
cuộc sống hơn thành ra là có thể có
những cái bạn mà chuẩn là người phù hợp
với mấy ông chuẩn có thể bộ tương lai là
mấy ông mấy ngày nữa mấy người ấy sẽ đi
chơi ở những người khác em mấy ông cứ
thử nghĩ của anh xem có thấy xóa không
còn đấy mới thấy sáu gì một lần Ông tìm
sớm hơn hay là ông chấp nhận là mình ok
Bây giờ mình không tìm được thì mình cắm
đầu vào làm kiếm tiền để phía sau kiếm
bạn làm mà
khi tổn hơn những cái bạn nói cho những
cái bạn mà bây giờ hẹn hò được với những
cái bạn đấy lại kiểu dạng mà vừa yêu vừa
chơi với nhau
Ừ không hẳn đã làm được với nhau đâu nên
là
cho nên làm để ông có thể chơi trò là
mấy ông cắm đầu vào sự nghiệp rồi về sau
yêu mình cái bạn cũng đã cắm đầu sự
nghiệp chưa ạ thì lúc đấy nó sẽ là phạm
trù khác
Thế mà lúc đấy là yêu cưới và yêu làm
được chúng mày yêu chơi nữa
em yêu trời đôi khi nó không cưới được
Ừ ok chưa Tôi nói những cái quan điểm
của rất rõ ràng đấy
I
know Em ở nhà làm được Tại sao không có
điện là có khi bạn đấy cũng ở trong kể
cái khóa học này của tôi mà bạn để cũng
đang ngồi nhà làm đồ ăn không
ở Đông Á
À hôm bảo vệ đấy hôm bảo vệ mấy ông hãy
cố tạo ấn tượng đi không những ấn tượng
với tôi ấn tượng với cả bạn đấy nữa thôi
bạn đấy sẽ có thể inbox ông vậy hôm
trước anh thấy trình ngầu thế đấy hết
Nếu phải Lạc quan như thế
Ừ ok Nói chung là video được Đúng tròn
hai tiếng thôi chúng ta tặng kết thúc
tại đây nhá mẹ ông xem cái gì đó đi rồi
tạm nghỉ đây chào mấy ông nhé Ok
ừ ừ